Ich brauche noch Picks, Picks, Picks, Picketypicks.
Ja, wir haben ja auch so Pickoverflow vom letzten Mal.
Sag mal, ist deine GitHub-Timeline auch seit ein paar Monaten einfach nur noch Schrott?
Du, es gibt da jetzt seit Neuestem...
Ich wollte nicht dahin, ich wollte dahin.
Da gibt's For You, Beta und Follow.
Ach lol, ich will einfach nur darüber switchen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das For You ist so ein Müll.
Das ist wie bei Twitter.
Ja.
Da gibt es ja auch
Following und For You ausgewählt.
Aber ja, ja.
Bei Twitter,
ich bin vielleicht der einzige Mensch,
der... Oh, nee, bei Twix meinst du.
Ach, nee, nehmen wir gar nicht auf.
Ich dachte Twix.
Twitter heißt jetzt Twix,
sonst ändert sich nichts.
Nein, nein, wenn du die Namen
zusammenlegst, heißt es Twix.
Twitter und X, Twix.
Aber
ich hätte auch gedacht, das heißt
eigentlich, Twitter heißt jetzt X,
sonst ändert sich nichts quasi,
aber Twix.
Ja.
Irgendjemand hatte geschrieben,
es gibt einen korrekten
Übersetzungskodex für latifiziertes
chinesisch, wo das
X vorne als
ausgesprochen hat.
Und XI sprichst du ja
Xi. Das heißt Shitter.
Ja, Shitter. Oder
Twish.
Aber Shitter, klar, logisch.
Ich habe es noch nicht
deinstalliert, aber ich habe jetzt erstmal zeitweise
den Auto-Update
auf meinem Telefon ausgemacht.
Da habe ich dieses hässliche Schließen-Logo
nicht gemacht. Wurdest du die App noch?
Ich habe seitdem Elon's gekauft, habe ich die deinstalliert
und war nicht mehr auf der Plattform, weil ich mich zeitweise eh nicht
anmelden konnte. Ich durfte ja nicht, weil
ich das Two-Factor-Window verpasst habe,
wo man Two-Factor ausschalten musste,
ohne Twitter-Blue-Subscriber zu sein.
Ach so.
Und ich habe die zwei Tage verpasst
und dann konnte ich mich nicht mehr anmelden,
weil Two-Factor für mich deaktiviert war.
Also für meinen Account war es noch aktiv,
aber ich durfte den Two-Factor-Service nicht nutzen.
Ich gehe immer davon aus, dass solche Sachen,
wenn das bei Twitter irgendwie announced wird,
dass das nach zwei Tagen wieder zurückgerollt ist,
weil sie merken, dass irgendwann nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ich habe auch gesehen, mittlerweile kann ich mich wieder anmelden,
aber interessiert mich halt nicht die Plattform.
Ich war nicht auf der Plattform.
Also wir schicken manchmal Leute Links.
Ich habe mittlerweile so eine Firefox-Extension am Laufen.
Lib Redirect heißt das Ding.
was diverse Sachen redirecten kann,
unter anderem aber auch direkt Shitter auf Nitter.
Und dann muss ich halt nicht mal selber auf Nitter gehen.
Nitter war kurzzeitig tot, aber ging zwei Tage später wieder.
Auf Nitter gibt es noch?
Nitter.net.
Nitter.net kommt irgendwas anderes.
Ein bisschen schade, weil du zwei Sachen ändern musst.
Da gebe ich jetzt meinen eigenen Username ein?
Ich war noch nie auf der Nitter Homepage, keine Ahnung, aber wahrscheinlich.
Und dann sehe ich jetzt hier...
Das ist eine Suche wahrscheinlich?
Das ist eine Suche, ah ja.
Aber so kannst du halt einfach, also
ich wieder wegte die automatisch und muss mich
halt nie wieder damit rumschlagen. Vor allem die
Twitter-Webseite ist so drecks langsam. Die war schon immer
langsamer, aber die ist jetzt noch langsamer.
Ja, ja. Und vor allen Dingen schmeißt die
mir dann immer dieses Login-Model
hin.
Hast du aber nicht gesehen, dass die seit heute, glaube ich,
so ein Feature drin haben, dass du als Twitter-Blue-Subscriber
jetzt deinen Blue-Haken verstecken
kannst, falls es dir peinlich ist, dass du
das sagst?
Ich meine, würde ich die Features
nutzen wollen, würde ich definitiv
also Twitter Blue nutzen wollen, würde ich definitiv
dieses Fit Teacher nutzen, aber
ich habe einfach null Interesse, auf dieser Plattform zu bleiben.
Ich war eh nie der große Twitter-Nutzer.
Wir haben Leute Links geschickt, die habe ich aufgemacht,
vielleicht geliked, wie tweeted, aber das war's.
Ich muss sagen, so gelegentliches Shitposting hat schon irgendwie Spaß gemacht,
aber... Das machst du ja
auf Mastodon weiter. Das mache ich jetzt auf Mastodon
irgendwie weiter und ich habe
ich habe jetzt seit kurzem
auch Ivory bei mir drauf und ich dachte, ich probiere
es mal aus, das macht wirklich viel aus, wenn du
einen guten Client hast, der sich gut anfühlt.
Also ich habe auch Metatext und Tut und was war das andere, was ich vorhin habe, das andere Tut ohne Ausrufezeichen oder so. Die waren alle super, aber ich muss sagen, irgendwas ist an Ivory anders, das ist einfach ein wesentlich schönerer.
Es fühlt sich richtig an irgendwie. Und ein Client macht halt 100% des Gefühls aus, was du mit der Plattform verbindest selber. Wenn du die normale Reddit-App oder Apollo genutzt hast, das war nicht derselbe Service dahinter. Klar, die Daten sahen letztendlich gleich aus, wenn du darüber nachdenkst, aber das ist nicht dieselbe Seite oder dieselbe Plattform gewesen.
Ich muss auch leider sagen, bei Mastodon funktionieren einige Sachen wirklich im Nicht-Web-Client besser. Dadurch, dass du Zugriffe von einer Webseite auf die andere machst, hast du häufig Kursprobleme oder ähnliche Probleme, wenn ich auf ein Profil gehe und das ist tatsächlich auf dem Mobile-Gerät ganz gut.
Ja, du kriegst halt einen Link zu irgendwas und dann, oh, Folge der Person. Oh, die kann ich ja nicht, weil das ist ja irgendeine Random-Seite, auf der ich gerade bin.
Ich muss auf der Seite irgendwie mir das rauskopieren,
das bei mir reinkopieren, oder ich gehe
hier auf dieses Login von dieser
Seite aus. Es ist, also
ich mag ja Mastodon, aber da ist noch einiges dran zu...
Also auch da gibt es
witzigerweise eine Firefox-Extension, die das besser macht.
Da trägst du deinen Mastodon-Händel an.
Das gibt es in letzter Zeit so gut mit Firefox aus.
Ich bin voll umgestiegen. Ich bin wieder,
ich war vor Ewigkeiten, vor bestimmten 15 Jahren
Firefox-User das letzte Mal.
Und vor kurzem hat mich Orion, der Third-Party-Webkit-Browser,
den ich benutzt habe, so hart angekotzt.
Ja, es ist noch ein Mac. Hendrik schaut gerade auf.
Nee, aber ich habe das letzte Mal vor Ewigkeiten Firefox genutzt.
Und Orion hatte mich jetzt irgendwie angekostet.
Ich war echt ein Fan von Orion.
Ich mag WebKit als solches.
Einfach nur, ich meine, ist ja letztendlich egal.
Mich würde es ja auch nicht darum wirklich kümmern.
Warte, das ist eine gute Überleitung später zu einem anderen Thema.
Da kommen wir noch zu.
Aber prinzipiell ist mir rein physikalisch egal,
welche Rendering-Engine drunter liegt.
Ob das jetzt Blink ist, ob das Webkit ist,
ob das Gecko ist oder das ist ein schöner
Firefox-Sticker.
Ich bin aufgestanden, um die große
Aufklebertüte zu holen.
Ein starker Stapel Rasticker.
Aber prinzipiell ist mir die Rendering-Engine ja egal,
aber ich mag einen schönen Browser drumherum haben.
Und ich fand es immer cool, Webkit zu nutzen, einfach nur
das klingt ein bisschen dumm, weil es halt
wenig Leute nutzen, im Sinne von, du willst
ja die Vielfalt irgendwie am Leben halten.
Was heißt wenige? Also gerade die ganzen
Apple-Laptica nutzen.
Also eigentlich jedes iOS-Gerät benutzt WebKit.
Ja, und das ist auch der Grund, warum Safari noch am Leben ist.
Wegen Mobile Safari.
Nicht wegen Mac-Nutzern, davon gibt es einfach zu wenige,
aber die ganzen iOS-Nutzern.
Safari selber hat wahrscheinlich so,
oder WebKit hat wahrscheinlich fünf Entwickler oder sowas.
Würde auch iOS oder würde Apple erlauben,
dass auf iOS andere Rendering-Engines
drin wären, dann
wäre WebKit tot von heute auf morgen.
Dann würden alle einen Chromium-Browser auf Mobile nutzen,
weil sie ja doch alle irgendwie Chrome nutzen
oder was anderes. Aber das ist ja auch alles
WebKit auf iOS.
Die Firefox-App ist ja auch WebKit-Browser auf iOS.
Aber das hat dahingestellt.
Ich fand Orion toll und vor allem,
weil es eine vertikale Tabbar hatte.
Da habe ich mich einfach so reingelebt gehabt,
weil einfach du hast den Platz,
du siehst mehr als das Favicon
und Orion ist aber auf Dauer...
Du hast letztes Mal schon drüber geredet.
Ja, ich glaube schon. Aber es ist immer langsamer geworden
und dann brauchte ich was anderes. Dann war ich kurzzeitig
sogar wirklich ein Chrome-Nutzer, weil einfach
ich dachte, ich bin...
Keine Ahnung.
Aber das fühlte sich kacke an
und das fühlte sich ekelhaft an.
Und dann bin ich zu Firefox und habe gemerkt,
TreeStyleTab ist ja doch eine schöne Extension.
Vor allem, du kannst ja mittlerweile auch
immer noch mittlerweile haben.
Also du benutzt jetzt Firefox?
Ich benutze voll Firefox auf fünf Geräten.
Aber du kannst ja sogar mit UserChrome
immer noch deine UI ein bisschen anpassen.
So habe ich die Tab-Leiste oben gekickt,
diese hässlichen Header von TreeStyleTab rausgekickt
und habe jetzt einen minimalistischen Browser
mit einer vertikalen Seitenleiste,
was ich richtig toll finde.
aus wie Firefox, was du da hast. Das ist spannend.
Das sind zwei Änderungen, literally zwei Änderungen.
Also wenn ich mir meinen dagegen
angucke, das sieht richtig
altbacken aus, was ich hier habe.
Mit zwei Leisten.
Früher, wenn man seine Eltern
besucht hatte, die irgendwie in dem Browser
so 15 Extension Toolbars
installiert hatten, die man rausschmeißen
musste.
Das war ein altes Mien.
Ach, übrigens!
Hey, Kylian!
Hey, Hendrik!
Das ist übrigens akronymisierbar
Folge 56
Nein, Folge 55
Magst du einen Schnaps?
Krass, dass wir es zu 55
Mittlerweile jede Folge sagen wir irgendwie
Boah, wir sind schon
Sonst gibt es jetzt so lange Zeit
Nein, ich meine 55 ist eine Schnapszahl
Ja, es ist eine schöne Schnapszahl
56 ist bestimmt auch wieder irgendein Meilenstein
weil wir die 2030 rausbringen oder so.
2030?
Naja, ich glaube, die letzte ist ja auch schon wieder
bestimmt fünf Jahre her.
Diesmal haben wir es tatsächlich geschafft.
Ich bin stolz auf uns. Und was war jetzt der ausschlaggebende
Punkt, dass du auf Firefox umgestiegen bist?
Wie gesagt, weil Orion lahm war.
Es ist laggy
geworden. Das hat mir missfallen.
Die haben echt viele tolle Features in dem Browser drin.
Ich mag den, aber
die App ist lahm geworden auf meinem System.
Ist das irgendwie... Ich habe neulich für irgendeinen
anderen Browser auch Werbung gesehen, wo sie
Werbung für gemacht haben.
Aber ich finde nicht brave, oder?
Nicht brave, aber ich denke mir auch immer,
das ist cool,
das ist krass, dass Leute andere Browser rausbringen.
Also ich finde es gut.
ARC meinst du?
Die haben kurz vor kurzem ihre Waiters abgeschafft
und die kannst du jetzt einfach runterladen.
Ja, ich glaube, das hatte ich auch.
Die machen ja auch sehr viele spannende Dinge,
aber die sind auch ein Chromium-basierter Browser,
wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Und die haben ein cooles Seitenleisten-Konzept,
da steckt auch viel Logik mit dahinter
und auch viele coole, tatsächlich neue Features.
Und was die halt richtig spannend machen,
ist das ganze Ding, ist eine Swift-App.
Auch auf Windows.
Cool.
Die bauen halt ihr eigenes UI-Framework für Swift auf Windows
und treiben das halt voran.
Die sind die, literally die Ersten, die das so machen.
Ich schätze, dann wird es dir wohl nicht lange geben.
Die gibt es schon eine Weile jetzt.
Echt, ja?
Ein paar, zwei, drei Jahre?
Nee, zwei Jahre vielleicht oder so?
Zumindest den Hot-Tag, den ich gerade rausholen wollte,
ist es einen eigenen Browser rauszuhauen.
es ist halt irgendwie kein Geschäftsmodell,
oder? Was ist denn das Geschäftsmodell?
Keine Ahnung.
Das, was du den Leuten da verkaufen kannst,
sind alles Einschnitte in deren Privatsphäre.
Wahrscheinlich. Du kannst mir anbieten
als Service, holst du deine Bookmarks
oder deine Passwörter bei uns.
Wie monetarisiert man das?
Das, was Brave macht,
irgendwie deine Eyeballs
an andere Verkaufende oder sowas.
Die verkaufen also ihre eigene Kryptowährung mit den Brave Attention Tokens.
Irgendso was, ja.
Aber so wie man Geld macht, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Das war bei Orion zumindest ganz klar.
Die wollen, dass du Geld zahlst für ein Account.
Musst du nicht, kannst du aber.
Und die betreiben noch ihre komplette Kagi-Search-Plattform
nebenher und Kagi-AI und Kram
und wollen, dass du dafür ein Pro-Account zahlst.
Und die Search-Plattform, wenn du deren Search-Engine nutzen willst,
die kannst du nur mit einem bezahlten Account nutzen.
Also es ist mittlerweile ein ähnliches Geschäftsmodell
wie das, was Mozilla macht,
die irgendwie noch irgendwelche Zusatz-Services anbieten,
die nichts mit dem Browser zu tun haben.
Vermutlich, weil mit dem Browser alleine, wie du schon meinst,
ist es echt schwer wahrscheinlich.
Der Grund, was ich mir rausgehört habe, von irgendeinem ehemaligen Mozilla-Entwickler, kann grob falsch sein, was die Hauptsage ist, aber der Hauptgrund Firefox oder Gecko weiterzuentwickeln war, dass Mozilla bei diesen W3C-Meetings einen Platz am Tisch hat, dass die mitreden können bei Webentscheidungen.
Aber ansonsten ist den Browser an sich entwickeln kein Zweck für sich. Außer halt natürlich aus idealistischen Gründen, du möchtest halt einen Browser haben, der ein besserer Browser ist als an sich.
Ja, finde ich als Nutzer auch toll, aber ich verstehe nicht, also wie bringt es denen monetären Vorteile, an den V3C Meetings teilzunehmen? Außer, dass sie da sind.
Das gibt in dem, also Mozilla, in dem Sinne wohl keinen monetären Vorteil, aber es sind halt eine Organisation, die sich für freies, offenes Netz einsetzt und deswegen möchten sie mitbestimmen, weil wenn das nur von Corporations mit finanziellem Interesse da mitbestimmt wird, dann ist das natürlich auch nicht gut.
Na klar.
Was hat Google, Apple und Microsoft, was haben die für Grunde ihre eigenen Browser zu entwickeln?
bei Google ganz klar, logisch.
Die bestimmen das
Internet. Und das bringt uns ja herrlich
zu unserem ersten wirklichen Thema für heute.
Wir haben tatsächlich ein paar
Themen, aber jetzt
fangen wir doch direkt mit dem
Schwergewicht an von
der Web Environment Integrity.
Oh wei, oh wei, oh wei.
Wenn wir über der Google Marktmacht sind.
Ihr habt es ja wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen,
dass Google da ein Proposal
rausgebracht hat, eine Referenz,
auf jeden Fall haben sie was auf GitHub geschmissen auch,
wo sie angefangen haben, was zu zeigen,
wie sie sich die APIs vorstellen, wie das Ganze aussehen wird.
Und was geht?
Es geht...
Was ich krass finde, ist,
das ist gar nicht unter dem GitHub-Account von Google,
sondern von Rupert Ben Weiser persönlich,
wenn ich den richtigen GitHub-Fork hier gefunden habe.
Ja, das ist jemand, der bei Google arbeitet.
Aber der sich wahrscheinlich sehr viel Hate ins Leben gezogen hat.
Ach was.
Das war strategisch vielleicht auch nicht so klug.
Er ist auch einer der Authors.
Ja, okay, genau, der erste.
Also worum geht es?
Es gibt irgendwie dieses, es gibt ein Web-Integrity-Proposal.
Web-Environment-Integrity-Proposal.
Und ich habe mir das heute nochmal durchgelesen.
Mein Licht blinkt, das liegt, ich habe noch nicht debatt, warum das manchmal vielleicht irgendein Skript wird gelauncht, wenn irgendwas mit dem Gäste-WLAN passiert, ich weiß es nicht. Es gibt ein Web-Inviorment-Integrity-Proposal und ich weiß gar nicht, wie der Implementation-State davon ist, es ist in Chromium schon drin, wenn sowas passiert, dann ist es meistens wahrscheinlich in Chromium schon drin.
Im Chromium ist es glaube ich, also war die Reformentsprinzip schon drin. Im Public Chrome ist es noch nicht gelandet, soweit ich weiß. Aber es ging echt schnell. Sie haben es auch vorangebracht. Aber ja genau, um was geht es denn eher spezifisch?
Environment Integrity. Also wenn ich eine Webseite bin, dann möchte ich sicherstellen, dass wenn ich aufgerufen werde, ich nicht von modifizierten Browsern oder anderweitigen HTTP-kompatiblen Anwendungen aufgerufen werde, die dann zum Beispiel Videos runterladen, anstatt sie einfach abzuspielen.
oder die dann Spam abschicken oder die Bots sind und irgendwie Fake News verbreiten
oder die einfach Adblocker installieren und sich meine Werbung nicht angucken wollen.
Da fängt der Spaß an.
Und wenn man sich die Goals hier durchliest und die Begründung davon,
es klingt so, wenn man so von außen rangeht, erst mal gar nicht so verkehrt,
weil die Begründung ist eigentlich, du möchtest ja sicher sein
und du möchtest ja, sie haben sehr viel in diesem Text mit so Fake News und Social Media und Participants und Bots argumentiert, was ich witzig finde.
Da gibt es sicher auch Probleme, also es ist nicht so, als ob das von ungefähr kommt.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie ausschließlich mit der Motivation, Adblocker zu killen, da rangehen, aber...
Und sie argumentieren, es geht hier darum, dass es ein Low-Entropy-Mechanism sein soll.
Also es geht quasi darum, das auch noch so zu implementieren, dass man nicht unbedingt einen Tracking-Mechanismus damit schafft, indem man sagt, du bist attestiert ein Mensch, dein Browser ist attestiert ein Menschenbrowser.
Das brauchst du ja nicht, das hast du ja dann auf einer tieferen Ebene.
Und was genau macht jetzt dieses Web Environment Integrity Proposal genau?
Also deine Webseite kann sagen, ich möchte sicher gehen, dass da ein echter Nutzer mit einem echten System mit bestimmten Features vor mir sitzt und kann deinen Browser auffordern, sich selbst attestieren zu lassen gegenüber einem Third-Party-Service, wie zum Beispiel einem Google-Server. Und dann muss dein Browser erst zu dem Google-Server gehen, sich so eine Challenge lösen, wie auch immer die dann aussieht, lokal irgendwelchen Code ausführen, wahrscheinlich irgendwas machen, um sicher zu gehen.
Das haben Sie nicht so richtig spezifiziert, wie das funktionieren soll.
Das soll wohl auch recht generisch sein, aber das lässt halt Türen offen für alles. Aber gut, dann wird Chromium natürlich mit irgendeinem Feature shippen, wo es sich selber sein Environment checken kann, wo es bestätigen kann, was für Extensions du installiert hast, was du sonst so auf deinem System hast.
Ich würde jetzt so was Naives machen wie, ist meine Binary von Google gesigned?
Genau. Du kannst deine Checksamt checken, ob das alles passt, ob deine Searchs da sind. Also das kannst du alles dann lokal machen und kann sich dann eben von diesem Service attestieren lassen, dass alles passt.
Und dann kriegst du von dem Service einen Token und mit dem Token darfst du deinen ursprünglichen Request wieder absetzen und hast letztendlich die Bestätigung, dass das Environment so, wie sagt man auf Deutsch, integer ist.
Dass es integer ist, genau.
Ja, genau.
Dass ich keinen gehackten Browser verwende.
Also ist an sich konzeptionell recht einfach an der Stelle, aber ist halt, wie wir es schon ein paar Mal gesagt haben, recht bitter, was das für Implikationen haben kann.
Vor allem voran ist natürlich die Frage, Googles Krieg gegen Adblocker geht damit groß weiter.
In der nächsten Runde quasi.
auf Mastodon habe ich jetzt schon gelesen von Leuten,
die dann gefragt haben, ja, was kann ich denn jetzt
überhaupt noch für einen Browser, der nicht
einen nicht-Chromium-basierten
Browser verwenden, der nicht Firefox ist und
jemand im Fall, nimm Ice Weasel.
Wow, das gibt's noch.
Und der sagt, oh, das klingt gut, davon habe ich
noch nie gehört, den werde ich mal ausprobieren.
Ich muss dann alles so schmunzeln, der hat mich gleichzeitig
ein bisschen alt gefühlt.
Ich muss nicht dazu sagen,
dass Ice Weasel der Trademark
freie Firefox auf Debian ist.
Aber das gibt's noch?
Das können wir nachher mal nachdenken.
Das ist auch so ein 20 Jahre altes Projekt.
Das ist ja eigentlich nur,
das ist wie relativ
einfach. Wahrscheinlich nicht gestorben, weil es per se nicht sterben
kann.
Oh, der erste Hit ist
irgendwie auf Sourceforge. Okay, es ist tot.
So viel dazu.
Es gibt irgendwelche Forks auf GitHub.
Oh, geticeweasel.org
Das Logo ist süß, aber es sieht schon ein bisschen
gut aus. Oh ja, die Seite hat ja irgendwie
einen User Agent String mit 2006 drin.
Vielleicht gibt es noch irgendjemanden, der es baut.
Anyway, Web-Integrity,
Web-Environment-Integrity, warum sage ich das immer falsch?
Web-Environment-Integrity-Proposals. Das haben sie jetzt
gelauncht, das haben sie auch irgendwie fachlich ganz gut geschrieben. Ich finde es schön, dass das hier eine GitHub-Seite ist
mit einem Explainer und dass da Embedded Mermaid
Sequenzdiagramme sind und wie gut
die in GitHub funktionieren.
Ich denke, oh, das ist schick,
das möchte ich auch.
Sie catchen dich mit cooler Doku.
Mit sowas kriegt man wieder.
Die hatten mich fast überzeugt.
Ich meine, klar,
Firefox wird das eh nicht einbauen.
Und deswegen ging ich jetzt davon aus,
dass du deswegen auf Firefox gewechselt bist.
Aber
das stimmt gar nicht.
Das war noch davor.
bevor Way um die Ecke kam.
Aber die Frage,
was Plattformen damit machen, ist ja jetzt eine gute Frage.
In Chromium und Chrome wird es ja
so oder so drin sein.
Die ganzen Chromium-Derivate,
Vivaldi, Opera, Edge,
Brave, die können halt
vorerst natürlich selber
entscheiden, ob sie das mit reinbauen.
So wie ich gehört habe, haben sich
Brave und Vivaldi schon dagegen ausgesprochen?
Sie haben sich dagegen ausgesprochen.
Obst du zum Schluss klein beigeben,
ist eine andere Frage.
Ich mag die Leute hinter Brave nicht,
aber ich traue der Firma tatsächlich zu.
Die haben keine Marktmacht, die sind eh viel zu klein.
Die können an sich machen, was sie wollen.
Aber ich mag die Leute eh nicht.
Es ist ja Brendan Eich, der JavaScript-Typ,
der CEO von Brave, auch dieses homophobe Arschloch.
Der spendet ja aktiv Geld für Kampagnen gegen die gleichgeschlechtliche Ehe.
Ich kann ihn überhaupt nicht leiden.
Der ist bestimmt einfach bloß ein überzeugter Christ.
Bestimmt, ja, ja.
einfach auf Upstream zu bleiben für die, meine ich.
Die müssen ja nicht jetzt einen Hardfork machen
und dann für immer weiter selber Chromium maintainen.
Das ist ja nicht der Fall.
Also es ist schon, so wie es aussieht,
recht einfach für die, das rauszunehmen
oder gar nicht erst reinzunehmen, das Feature.
Aber die Frage ist halt, was ist mit großen Plattformen?
Was ist, wenn halt Netflix sagt, ja nee,
wir wollen, dass nur noch Leute das nutzen,
die halt Way supporten.
Und Netflix ist halt groß genug,
also es nutzen eh, wie viel Prozent da draußen
Chrome, 80, 90 Prozent der Leute?
Also Netflix ist glaube ich nochmal ein anderes
Thema oder allgemein so Videostreaming-Seiten,
weil es bereits eh
diese DRM-Extensions gibt
und die hat vorausgesetzt,
also die hast du entweder oder der hast du nicht
und
vielleicht gibt es schon irgendwelche gehackten Browser,
die so, aber eigentlich,
ich weiß nicht genau, wie diese DRM-Extensions
funktionieren,
aber im Endeffekt würde das dann wahrscheinlich
darauf hinauslaufen, dass du für 90 Prozent
aller Sachen einen Browser nimmst und
paar Sachen in anderen. Schwierig wäre es,
wenn es,
also solange sie es auf so Videostreaming-Sachen
bezieht, könnte ich
es noch irgendwie mitmachen. Das mache ich tatsächlich.
Für Netflix benutze
ich Safari oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Ich wollte irgendwie diese DRM-Extensions
in meinem Firefox auslassen.
Achso, okay.
Aber
wenn sie es irgendwie durchsetzt, dass es
auf anderen
Plattformen auch vorausgesetzt
wird, dann wird es natürlich umso kritischer.
Also hier, spannender wurde es
durch diesen anderen Artikel von
HTTP Toolkit, der so einen richtigen
hackernussischen Titel hat,
oder? Ja.
Apple already shipped a station
on the web and we barely noticed.
Ich meine, er hat recht, vor ein paar Jahren hat
Apple das als neues Feature eingebaut. Es wurde auch
nicht groß announced, aber es war bekannt.
Aber damals hat es halt niemand
quasi unter der Headline gesehen, was man damit
machen könnte.
Die haben halt
witzigerweise nicht die Marktmacht,
dass es bei denen wichtig ist.
Also Safari...
Mit iOS halt schon eigentlich.
Mit iOS ja, aber...
Vor allem in den USA.
Aber Chrome,
aber mit Safari auf dem Desktop und mit...
Nee, lol, also Safari auf dem Desktop
nutzt der quasi nicht. Also klar...
Ich meine, mit Chrome auf dem Desktop wäre das
dieses Web-Environment-Integrity-Ding schon
wesentlich krasser.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Vor allem mit Google
im Backend, die halt das Feature auch nutzen werden.
Und vielleicht sogar schon tun. Wer weiß, wie schnell das ging.
Also im Endeffekt werden sie damit sowas wie Alter Internet Explorer.
Wir machen einfach unser eigenes Web und ihr könnt auch schauen, wo ihr bleibt.
Also was Apple hier gemacht hat mit den Device Check APIs, die sie vor ein paar Jahren eingebaut haben,
ist, dass sie prinzipiell, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, mit Cloudflare kooperiert haben.
Und was gebaut haben, essentiell, dass Cloudflare auf dieselbe Art und Weise letztendlich deinem Device eine Challenge gibt.
dein Device geht dann zu einem Apple-Server, fragt
hier, gib mir mal bitte ein Token, dass ich wirklich ein
valides iOS-Gerät bin, was
auch im Hintergrund dann gecheckt wird, keine Ahnung,
wahrscheinlich einfach nur, also da hat
Apple ja im System alle Möglichkeiten,
das dann zu attestieren und
dann schickst du diesen Token halt wieder an Cloud-Server,
die dich dann halt nicht, also
diese typischen Capture-Checks
dir vorwerfen, das halt dann eben nicht tun,
weil du ja doch ein valides Gerät bist und nicht von
irgendeiner Click-Farm, die da gerade durchmöchst.
Das war noch so ein Sales-Point von diesem Web-Environment-Integrity-Dings,
das ist so verhindern, dass die Leute
jeden Mist Captures ausfüllen müssen, um zu beweisen,
dass sie keine Bots sind.
Ja.
Oh Mann.
Ich habe jetzt vor ein paar Tagen
einen Toot gesehen. Der Schmittlauch
hat den retootet, beziehungsweise
drunter geschrieben, dass er es auch gemacht hat. Fand ich eine witzige Idee.
Habe das auch direkt auf meiner Homepage eingebaut.
Ich checke jetzt auch immer auf meiner
Seite, ob du Web Environment
Integrity enabled hast, beziehungsweise ob du es
im Browser hast. Und falls ja,
dann gibt es einen Text, dass du doof bist und einen anderen Browser nutzen sollst.
Echt, ja?
Ich kann es halt noch nicht testen, weil ich keinen Browser habe, der das unterstützt.
Also auch aktuell ist Chrome, habe ich installiert.
Aber da sehe ich die Seite noch ganz normal.
Den haben wir es offenbar noch nicht.
Hast du dieses Chrome Canary, oder wie das heißt?
Ich habe es, glaube ich, nicht installiert.
Ich hatte mal irgendwie DevChrome auf irgendeiner anderen Kiste gegebenenfalls.
ich habe da die Maus, aber hier die Tastatur
Chrome
Dev habe ich, ja der aber wahrscheinlich
mir jetzt sagt, dass er schon seit Monaten
gelaufen ist und geupdatet werden möchte
Ach da ja
Update den mal
Chrome ist out of date
so, reinstall Chrome
Ach du musst das händisch
neu installieren? Ja, weil das irgendwie
weil ich diese ganzen Hintergrund-Services
nicht angemacht habe
Ah, sehr schön, das ist toll
Ja, das ist auch bei...
Anyway, die Extension
kannst du mir mal zeigen, die
kann ich mir dann auch auf meine kleine Miniseite
schmutz. Das spielt ja eh keine Rolle, weil
wer gibt schon als Besucher auf meine Homepage, aber ich fand
es einfach ein netzes Detail.
Aber ein interessanter Punkt ist eigentlich,
der hier in diesem HTTP-Toolkit
Blogpost erwähnt
wurde, ist, dass sich
Google das eigentlich nur
aus irgendwelchen Android-APIs
abgeguckt hat, die das eh schon machen.
Achso. Es gibt irgendwelche
Play,
ähm,
irgendwelche
Android Play
Integrity Attestation. Achso, da gibt's
das auch schon, das haben wir gar nicht mehr bewusst. Und
das kann,
so wie ich es verstanden habe,
dazu führen, dass du
zwar Lineage OS auf deinem Handy
laufen lassen kannst, aber dass trotzdem
zum Beispiel, wie sie hier genannt wird,
deine Bank-App sich dafür entscheiden kann,
auf deinem Telefon nicht
zu funktionieren, weil du
routetes Telefon hast, weil er nicht mehr
integer ist.
Diese ganzen Root-Checks, beziehungsweise auf iOS
auch diese J-Bag-Checks, das ist so hässlich,
ekelhaft.
Das ist auf iOS einfach bloß kein Problem,
weil kein Mensch mehr seiner Telefon...
Die J-Bag-Szene ist tot. Also machen noch Leute,
ja, aber...
Eigentlich ist es
ein Problem. Wir beschweren uns nicht über ein Problem, was
zum Beispiel
schon überhaupt nicht passieren kann auf iOS,
einfach weil man das System nicht
integer machen kann.
Aber ich meine, was ist denn das Argument von der Bank-App, das zu machen?
Die wollen ihre Kunden schützen, weil die ja dumm sein können,
aus Versehen ihr Handy routen oder was?
Und dann könnten sie ja mehr über drauf haben.
Ist das die Aussage? Geht es darum, dass aus Versehen meine Oma ihr Android-Gerät geroutet hat?
Irgendwie zweifle ich das an.
Das war jetzt auch ein nicht existentes Beispiel.
Tja, du möchtest halt irgendwie, es ist genauso, wie weshalb deine Firma irgendwie sicherstellt, dass auf deinem Dienstlaptop nichts installiert ist, was sie nicht erlauben, einfach damit sie keinen...
Oder ist das eher die Angst, dass Leute die Banking-Apps auseinandernehmen und reverse-engineeren, weil sie auf einem gerutelten System sind und die Möglichkeiten dazu haben?
Und plötzlich gibt es CCC-Vorträge über deine Bank.
Shut up and take my money.
Der war toll.
Müssen wir mal eine Liste machen.
Tja, aber das war ja, aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich meine Gedanken dazu formulieren soll. Das ist doch aber ein Schrott-Argument. Mich kotzt das an, dass Banken oder generell auch andere Apps dann da diese Muse haben, so viel Scheiße machen zu wollen auf meinem System. Das ist mein System, die sollen sich gefälligst mal einfach wie ein normaler Plattform-Citizen aufführen und nicht einfach da denken, sie können sonst was für Rechte haben. Das ist mein System. Fuck you.
Ja, und das ist halt dieses Hin und Her zwischen, ich verkaufe, also die Infrastrukturbetreiber und die Plattformhersteller, was Microsoft für Windows ist und Apple für Mac und Google für das gesamte Internet.
Oder zumindest sieht sich wahrscheinlich Google zu einem gewissen Punkt als Gatekeeper für Web-Anwendungen.
Zumindest für die, wo Werbung läuft, die von Google gehostet wird.
die sagen, das ist unser Haus, da kannst du nicht einfach
mit deinen Spielzeugen drin spielen, installier doch dein eigenes
Betriebssystem auf einem Computer, wo das noch geht
und dann geht das aber noch nicht in unserem Browser, in unserem Web
auf unserem Windows oder auf unserem Apple
Ach, das ist eine Kacke
In Akronomisierbar 56 haben wir die Überschrift
Kea benutzt jetzt Linux.
Nee, das ist doch...
Och Mann, ich bin unglücklich.
Aber man kann sich noch erfreuen
an den Pull Requests.
Nein, Quatsch, an den Issues, die auf diesem...
Es gab auch Pull Requests, die wurden halt
alle geschlossen.
24 geklost. Es gab wahrscheinlich welche, die
Create Code of Conduct,
Update Code of Conduct, Clarify
something. Es gab wahrscheinlich viele, die einfach...
Fixing Problems, was hat denn der gemacht?
Der hat wahrscheinlich
Einfach alles gelöscht.
Per request, alles gelöscht.
Sehr schön.
Ich fand das Issue toll mit
Wow, thank you for creating the Torment Nexus
from the famous sci-fi novel. Please don't create the
Torment Nexus. We are giving corporations full control
over all aspects of people's domestic lives.
Wurde natürlich gelockt und
geschlossen.
Gab es das nicht irgendwie?
Das war Issue 100.
Das Torment Nexus kenne ich auch bloß von
in so einem Shitpost, wo es hieß,
das nächste Android-Phone
heißt nicht mehr Pixel, sondern wieder
Nexus, aber diesmal Torment
Nexus.
War's das?
Ich glaube, wir können mal den Ursprung des Begriffs drunter
in die Showdowns packen.
Aber
ja, Leute beschweren sich in den Issues.
Ich finde es auch krass, dass die Themen...
Also, kann man Issues schließen überhaupt?
No, please don't do this.
Does not explain what the cost
of the restrictions, of restricting
Fraud. Ein paar davon sind sehr sinnvoll.
User Research?
Google bordering
on antitrust.
Do not listen to the ad-blocking addicts.
Please ship this ASAP.
Oh Mann, oh Mann, oh Mann.
Aber entspannend,
dass Google das auf GitHub getan hatte, unter einem
privaten Account. Das war unerwartet.
Das stimmt.
Ich meine,
selbst wenn du das
nicht auf deinem privaten Account gehabt hättest,
da hättest du irgendwie die Autoren drüber gehabt.
Wahrscheinlich war es,
ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich dabei gedacht haben, wir schreiben
mal lieber nicht oben fett in die URL
github.com slash google,
um irgendwie diesen potenziellen,
diese Kritik auf uns
zu ziehen, sondern
wir machen das einfach mal hier auf einem eigenen
Account. Das hat der Typ sonst
so gemacht.
Ah ja, gut, okay.
Nicht so viel auf GitHub zumindest.
Vielleicht gibt es ihn gar nicht, vielleicht ist das ein Fake-Account.
Ja, das
Also passt auf, was in euren Browsern läuft
ihr könnt auf
kean.io
nachgucken, ob ihr die Extension schon installiert habt
vielleicht, also ich meine, da musst du
den Leuten nicht sagen, du bist so doof, weil du diesen Browser
Es steht nicht, du bist doof
Wenn du das hier lesen kannst, dann brauchst du Hilfe
Installiere der Firefox
hier, aber
Ich verlinke auch noch auf Safari, also referenziere
auch Safari als Alternative
das ist natürlich fragwürdig, aber
immer noch besser als Google an der
Stelle.
Und hattest du jetzt irgendwo gehört, ob Firefox
ein Statement dazu oder Mozilla ein Statement
dazu abgegeben hat? Also Statement von Mozilla habe ich nichts gehört
bisher. Aber man erwartet
natürlich nicht, dass sie
das direkt mit implementieren. Wir werden augenblicklich in unserem
Matrix-Channel korrigiert werden,
ob das nur passiert ist oder nicht.
Es ist ja, also Mozilla weiß ich
halt auch nicht, was ich von Mozilla halten soll.
Die haben sich halt schon in beide Richtungen benommen
und zwar auch sehr häufig in die falsche.
Weißt du noch, dieses Klicks-Debakel damals?
Äh, nee.
Diese deutsche Firma CELQZ,
die dann die gesamte Browser-History
bekommen haben, war eingebaut in den Browser.
Also für ein Subset von
10% der Nutzer und zwar nur aus Deutschland oder so.
Aber die haben zu Testzwecken einfach
denen dann die gesamte Browser-History geschickt.
War im Browser als Feature.
Ich glaube, das ist das ewig Konto.
Das war, ja, das Geschichte habe ich gar nicht mehr so richtig
in Konto. Das ist auch ewig her, aber das sind halt
so Entscheidungen, die Mozilla manchmal trifft, wo du dir halt denkst,
ich meine, ich nutze euch aus dem Grund
wahrscheinlich nach irgendwelchen
Monetarisierungsstrohhalmen so
auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall
sonst würden die sonst was gar nicht tun
das ist halt das eine, wo ich
an sich, ich hoffe, jemand korrigiert
mich nicht, weil das mein Weltbild zerstören
würde, also krass, okay
das klingt sehr Corporate
Overlordy hier, aber ich
nutze gerne Apple-Systeme
einfach nur, weil es für Apple lohnenswert
ist, zu sagen, dass ihnen Privacy wichtig ist
die Nutzer-Privacy wichtig ist
und sie damit werben und das als Feature sehen,
weil sie damit Geld verdienen können auch.
Das finde ich gut, solange unsere Interests da
aligned sind. Ich hoffe, sie sind auch
aligned und ich behaupte auch, dass das bisher
alles ganz gut funktioniert.
Aber irgendwann könnte es halt auch nicht mehr der Fall sein.
Who knows?
Beziehungsweise die interessante Auslegung
von diesen Interests könnte das natürlich auch
zur Folge haben, dass ich da überhaupt nicht mehr da
kommen bin. Es ist ein schöner
Glaube und Glauben sind ja auch immer dazu da,
dass man irgendwie mit dieser
Scheißwelt besser klarkommt, ob du nur an ein Leben
nach dem Tod glaubst oder daran, dass Apple
dich nicht ausspioniert.
Solange du dich an diesem Glauben festhältst, kannst du, glaube ich,
ein relativ zufriedenes Leben führen.
Die Krux bei Apple ist halt, dass
deren Software grundlegend
nicht Open Source ist und du dementsprechend
nicht ausschließen kannst, dass sie dich nicht schon längst
an die NSA
verraten haben.
Und wenn es morgen rauskommen
würde, dass Apple dich
überwacht und dich ausspioniert,
würdest du dann zu Android wechseln?
Es gibt nur,
wie war das mit
die Simpsons Halloween-Folge mit
Kodos und Kang, die sich als Präsidentschaftskandidaten
ausgeben? Es ist ein Zwei-Parteien-System.
Was willst du machen?
Du kannst
Pest und oder
Cholera.
Ja, wenn dann schon und Cholera.
Das ist alles scheiße.
Was gibt es denn noch so für
andere schöne Sachen? Lass uns doch mal über
was Freudiges reden. Hast du dir schon
hast du dich schon für so ein App-Evision-4 angemeldet?
Ich habe mich für das DTK tatsächlich angemeldet,
aber als ob ich die Chance
bekommen würde.
Ich habe gehört, von den Dingern werden bloß tausend Stück hergestellt
werden oder sowas. Insgesamt meinst du?
Oder? Naja, in Deutschland ist
jetzt schon hergestellt worden und sie können sich nicht mehr leisten,
noch mehr herzustellen und müssen auch, dass sie sie wirklich
verkaufen. Deutschland
dauert ja noch eine Weile, bis wir irgendwann diese
Hardware mal sehen können. Ich habe mir
für das DTK, für das Developer-Toolkit, dass du
das Ding vorab bekommst und da deine App für bauen kannst,
musst dir sogar einen kleinen Bewerbungstext schreiben, was du denn
planst, damit zu machen.
Ich hab gesagt, ich plane ganz futuristische ÖPNV-Konzepte
umzusetzen, aber ich bin ja ein Privatentwickler.
Ich dachte, du schreibst da rein.
Ich sitze den ganzen Tag auf meinem Sofa und
gucke mir
schlüpfrige Filme damit an.
Nutzen kann ich das Ding sicher gut, aber
die Game-Ust ja begründen, was du dafür bauen möchtest.
Ich portiere mit dem,
wie heißt das, GPT,
mit dem Game-Porting-Toolkit
Microsoft Flight Simulator
mit dem Ding. Das würde ich gerne machen.
Ich spiele gerade wieder Microsoft Flight Simulator in VR.
Das ist echt toll.
In VR echt viel Spaß das Spiel.
Ich muss mal zu dir zu Besuch kommen.
Und Beat Saber natürlich. Beat Saber ist einfach das beste VR-Spiel.
Ja, aber...
Also du hast dich angemeldet,
dann würdest du dann so ein Toolkit kriegen?
Ja, also man darf es dann wahrscheinlich
für nur 1000 Euro kaufen oder so.
Ja, das ist klar.
Ich weiß es noch nicht, ich kriege keine Ahnung.
Bei dem TV war es damals ganz cool,
bei dem Apple TV, da habe ich mich auch für das Developer Toolkit angemeldet
und dann durfte man es für einen symbolischen Euro kaufen.
Weißt du, wie viele Apps ich dafür gebaut habe?
Gar keine.
Also ich habe, glaube ich, ein Jahrzehnt später
mal eine halbe App dafür gebaut.
Jetzt gibt es natürlich
Volltextsuche in Audioaufzeichnungen.
Ich habe so viele
coole Sachen ausprobiert. Ich habe das maßgeblich
mit vorangetrieben, die Plattform.
Nice. Ich bin stolz auf der IKR.
Das passiert ja in TVOS
auch nichts mehr. Das ist ja abgehangen.
Da ist ja alles drin an Features, was so geht.
Mehr ist nicht.
Was ist eigentlich der grundlegende Unterschied an
diesen ganzen OSes für
Apple, außer dass
die einfach ein slightly
anderes Desktop-Environment
haben. Naja, sie sind potenziell
abgespeckt. Auf WatchOS läuft natürlich
nicht alles, was auf iOS mit draufläuft.
Essentiell sind das alles
iOS-Forks. Also iOS
MacOS-Fork, da mal Coco Touch.
Es heißt nicht
iPhone OS, es heißt iOS. Es hieß
Anfangs iPhone OS, ganz am Anfang.
Und dann sieht man macOS auch noch OS 10.
So wie Twitter
10 heißt.
Es gibt so ein herrliches
Video, es gibt doch diese alte
historische Aufnahme, wo sie irgendwo in Nürnberg
auf dem Reichstagsgelände oder so
das große Hakenkreuz oben auf dem Gebäude springen.
Das hat da einer auch umgeschoppt
mit, es wird das Twitter-X auf dem Gebäude
springen.
Ich habe den Tweet gelesen
gehabt, dass ein X doch auch bloß ein
Sansseriefes Hakenkreuz ist.
Ja.
Das passt zur Plattform.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen iOS und iPadOS wirklich?
Warum gibt es zum Beispiel dieses komische Lockscreen-Feature nicht auf dem iPad?
Warum sie das iPhoneOS und das iPadOS in zwei getrennte Beziehungssysteme aufgelöst haben, kann ich hier nicht sagen.
Da steckt wahrscheinlich der Wunsch dahinter, dass sie mehr Split machen können in Zukunft.
Und bisher sieht man das nur anhand von Features, die die eine Plattform nicht bekommt oder erst ein Jahr später bekommt.
also das
aber technisch würde es mich nicht wundern, wenn das intern
exakt dasselbe Bild ist mit ein paar Flags, dass das
eine halt die Features nicht bekommt oder so
ich kann nur
so viel sagen, es ist keine gute Idee
interne Produkte zu forken
selber
es ist keine gute Idee, macht's nicht
das hab ich auch schon gemacht, das funktioniert bei uns sehr gut
also zeitweise
macht's nicht
also wenn du
dieses Ding bekommen solltest
dann sag mal Bescheid
Also sie haben es aktuell stehen in den Bedingungen, aber das klingt eher so nach, die haben die Bedingungen nicht angepasst zu dem, was die Leuten schon gezeigt haben, die bevor dem Announcement so ein Ding bekommen haben. Das gibt es ja auch immer bei Apple, dass sie, also damals noch bevor das iPad rauskam, sind sie ja auch mit der Hardware zu großen Firmen hin, die Apps dafür bauen konnten, dass sie halt zum Launch, zum Announcement schon zeigen können und schaut mal was, damals noch die relevante Firma Evernote dafür gemacht hat zum Beispiel.
und das können sie ja gleich zum Announcement mitzeigen.
Damals hatten sie halt so lustige Sachen wie...
Machen sie ja regelmäßig, dass sie irgendwie andere Firmen zeigen,
die irgendwas krasses mit dem LiDAR-Scanner
auf dem iPhone gemacht haben.
Aber wenn du das halt zum Announcement der Hardware mitzeigen willst,
musst du den Leuten halt Pre-Release-Sachen geben
und vor allem Hardware bei einer neuen Plattform,
die noch niemand kennt.
Und da hat Apple halt sehr lustige Bedingungen.
Und ich weiß, beim iPad habe ich das damals mitbekommen gehabt,
da wurde das irgendwann veröffentlicht
und das fand ich super interessant.
Du hast halt ein Gerät bekommen,
du hast einen Tisch bekommen oder so.
Oder haben sie ein Gerät? Ich glaube, es war entweder ein Tisch oder ein Gerät ohne Case. Und das wurde aber in dem Tisch montiert. Und du musstest Apple zur Verfügung stellen, einen extra Raum in deiner Firma, der keine Fenster hat. Und der Raum muss gesichert sein, also mit dem Schloss. Und dieses Schloss oder Keycard, da dürfen nur bestimmte Mitarbeiter Zugriff haben. Also es muss extra abgesichert sein. Dann darf nicht einfach jeder reingehen können in diesen Raum.
Und sie haben sehr viele Fotos von diesem Raum und seiner Beschaffenheit gemacht, von Boden, von dem Tisch, wo es da remontiert wurde und von Wänden, dass wenn Bilder leaken, sie genau nachvollziehen können, wer das geleakt hat. Und dann bist du jetzt auf der Denial-List für zukünftige Arte wahrscheinlich. Aber die haben das schon sehr ernst genommen.
Und so ähnlich ist es aktuell wohl in den Bedingungen für das DTK mit drin, für die Brille, dass du sicherstellen musst, dass das immer nur du selber drauf Zugriff hast und das in einem abgeschlossenen Case gelagert wird.
Und wenn du in den Urlaub gehst, musst du irgendwie sicherstellen, dass da niemand anderes auf die Räumlichkeiten, wo sie gelagert wird, Zugriff haben oder dass du es zwischenzeitlich an Apple zurückschickst. Und das klingt alles so nach Bedingungen, das war halt vor dem Release der Brille. Also die Welt weiß, dass das Ding existiert jetzt. Klar, das haben die Leute noch nicht zu Hause in der Hand gehabt, aber das ist ein bisschen hart übertrieben, weil du dürftest an sich nicht mal deinen Partner mit dem Zusammenwohnzugriff auf das Ding ermöglichen.
Das ist ein bisschen lächerlich.
Aber ich vermute mal, das ist einfach nicht angepasst gewesen.
Und das ändern sie noch, sobald die Case dann rausgehen irgendwann.
Die Frage ist ja auch, für wie viel Geld darf man sich so ein Ding bieten?
Also ich bin nach wie vor überrascht, dass sie es überhaupt rausbringen.
Weil es überhaupt nicht in das Portfolio von ihnen passt.
Also es passt insofern
in das Portfolio, wie die
irgendwie 700 Euro Rollräder
für den Mac Pro in ihr Portfolio passen.
Was sich irgendwie
fünf Leute aus Gag-Weise zu viel
Geld haben, tatsächlich dazu holen werden.
Aber
es ist
kein wirklich
weltverbesserndes
Feature, was
weithin
benutzt werden wird.
Dafür ist es zu Nische und zu teuer.
Und ich habe den Eindruck, das ist zumindest meine These, der VR- oder AR-Hype ist eigentlich schon wieder vorbei.
Das ist so, es gab den Bitcoin-Hype und dann gab es eine Zeit lang den AR- oder VR-Hype oder Metaverse-Hype.
Die haben ja das tunlichst vermieden, in dem Marketingmaterial zu dem Ding irgendwelche von den bekannten Begriffen wie Virtual Reality oder Meta irgendwas zu verwenden.
einfach weil diese Begriffe alle schon durch die ganzen
Failures von Facebook
so verbrannt sind.
Aber das Ding ist ja an sich auch keine VR-Plattform
in erster Linie. Es ist halt für Mixed Reality
gedacht. Klar, der Markt
wird nie schick sein im Vergleich zu einem Smartphone.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass wir in 10
Jahren alle so eine Brille daheim haben, egal wie teuer die ist.
Auch wenn die super billig ist.
Es gibt jetzt schon affordable,
gut funktionierende...
Nee, da ist eben genau der Punkt. Es gibt nichts, was
gut funktioniert.
Es ist alles irgendwo Trash, was aktuell existiert.
Und vielleicht kannst du das aktuell nur für den Premium-Preis verlangen,
dass da halt was Gutes bei rauskommt.
Also ich hätte gesagt,
dass es irgendwie so einigermaßen hinreichend funktionierende
so VR-Headsets zum Spielen oder was gucken,
die gibt es schon hinreichend auf dem Markt.
Und ich habe nicht den Eindruck,
dass tonnenweise Leute sowas haben.
Alles hat Caveats davon.
Alles hat irgendwelche Shortcomings.
Entweder die Auflösung gibt es nicht her,
dass es halt auch nur halbwegs gut ausschaut.
Oder die Plattform ist generell Schrott und langsam.
Oder du hast keine Controller-Input-Möglichkeiten,
die sauber funktionieren. Also alles hat irgendwo irgendwelche Probleme.
Und bisher das Beste, was auf dem Markt existiert, ist auch das relativ hochpreisige,
wie sagt man das so, relativ teure Valve-Index-Ding.
Das ist halt, so wie ich das sehe, dass das Beste, was aktuell existiert,
hat auch die mit Abstand besten Controller, die dir halt die Möglichkeiten beben,
wirklich deine Hände, also komplett den Zustand deiner Hände zu tracken.
Also jeden Finger einzeln, ob der geschlossen ist oder offen ist.
Und so kannst du halt auch deine Hand offen haben,
weil die mit dem Strap an der Hand gehalten werden.
Und kannst du wirklich in der 3D-Welt greifen.
Klar, das ist für Gaming fantastisch.
Das ist VR und Apples Gerät hat halt hoffentlich gut funktionierendes,
das werden wir dann sehen, Handtracking,
wo du auch deine Hand direkt benutzen kannst.
Und mit Gesten und mit Handgesten da halt mit der Welt interagieren wirst.
Also mit deiner Mixed-Reality-Welt,
dann kannst du natürlich auch in der komplett VR-Welt,
Aber das ist anscheinend nicht das, worauf die Plattform den Hauptfokus setzt.
Aber auch nur, weil sie quasi ein bisschen late to the game sind
und irgendwie die Parameter modifizieren mussten,
sagen sie halt, das ist halt nicht VR.
Ja, und was machst du mit VR?
VR ist für Gaming da und das ist halt nicht Apples Stärke.
Vielleicht in Zukunft schon.
Ich will unbedingt auf dem Ding Beat Saber spielen.
Das ist das eine Spiel, was in VR der Hammer ist.
Ich meine, Hardware-mäßig sind sie jetzt da,
dass die Geräte gut genug sind,
um da auch krasse Spiele drauf zu spielen.
Easy, easy.
Also ich hätte eigentlich eher erwartet,
dass sie jetzt voll durchstarten und sagen,
wir wollen die neue Gaming-Plattform sein.
Und jetzt gibt es anstatt so einem Gaming-Headset
oder statt so einem AR, sorry, MA-Headset
gibt es jetzt Apple TV Plus mit,
das gibt es ja auch schon,
Apple TV Gaming oder sowas,
was irgendwie voller Hardware-Spec
und eine Kühlung drin hat,
was quasi so ein kleiner Mac Mini ist.
Einfach zum Spielen von Spielen.
Vielleicht können sie das nächstes Jahr ankündigen oder sowas.
Wir haben jetzt AAA-Windows-Games alle portiert
auf Metal.
Oder fuck it, wir haben es aufgegeben,
Metal zu pushen,
es läuft jetzt einfach DirectX auf Mac.
Ich meine, dafür haben sie an sich ja GPT gebastelt.
Ja, also es ist halt nicht so schön offen,
wie Proton es ermöglicht,
aber die Idee ist ja zumindest da, dass sie da hin wollen.
Und GPT ist da schon ein krasser Schritt,
also das Gameboarding-Toolkit.
Finde ich fantastisch.
Ich hoffe, das bringt auch was,
weil ich würde gerne mehr Spiele auch auf meinem Mac mitspielen.
Mal schauen.
Was ist auf deinem System eigentlich gerade los?
Ich weiß nicht, der ist irgendwie warm geworden.
Jetzt ist er wieder kalt.
Ich habe gerade das UTM abgeschossen.
Ich hatte gerade noch kurz, bevor du gekommen bist,
hier Arts Linux neu installiert.
Auf meinem Laptop,
NHVM.
Und jetzt wird er wieder kalt.
Ich bin seit kurzem Besitzer von einem
kleinen, handlichen
MacBook Air.
Von dem kleinen.
Ist das eigentlich dieses Midnight?
Dieses cool dunkelblau? Das ist dieses Midnight Blue.
Und ich muss sagen, mal vorab gesehen, dass es
wieder ein Apple-Computer ist, aber
Hättest du dich da vor 10 Jahren
gesehen, dass du Besitzer von mehreren Macs bist?
Nee, tatsächlich nicht.
Dadurch, dass ich
auch auf Arbeit
quasi gezwungenermaßen
Computer benutze, habe ich mich leider
sehr dran gewöhnt. Und
als ich von Avahi Linux
gehört habe, dachte ich mir, na gut, okay, wahrscheinlich
ist die beste Hardware, wenn man sich sowas holen möchte,
tatsächlich so ein Gerät. Und ganz ehrlich,
ich habe das jetzt hier gerade in der Hand
im Vergleich zu den MacBook Pros
mit ihren Legacy-Anschlüssen,
die sie wieder
rückverbaut haben. Was habe ich hier für Legacy-Anschlüssen?
HDMI und irgendwelche
alten Fotokarten.
Ich habe mir vor,
es hätte auch Compact Flash, das wäre geil.
hat dieses Mini einfach den perfekten Laptop-Formfaktor.
Ich meine schon mal, wie dünn das ist und wie leicht.
Es ist schon schön.
Ich glaube, wir sollten wirklich mal irgendwann von Apple Geld verlangen,
weil das ist ein Werbepodcast.
Ja, aber ansonsten so, also 100% zufrieden bin ich nicht damit natürlich,
aber es ist schön unterwegs mal was hacken zu können.
Und ich habe, wie gesagt, ich habe mir wieder Artikeln und Lust drauf gezogen.
Ich benutze es nicht 100% der Zeit,
Aber ich code da drauf.
Das ist cool.
Ich habe auch gesehen, dass es Neo-Wim da drin schon am Laufen.
Ja, ja.
Ich werde ja auch alt.
Ich habe mal die einfachere Variante genommen, es zu installieren
und habe mich für Arschboot entschieden.
Und da wird man am Anfang gefragt,
ob man Nano...
Das war eine Simpsons-Folge, oder?
Da, wo sie nach Australien gehen
und dann macht Bart irgendwas Illegales
und die Strafe ist, dass ihm von einem
riesigen Stiefel in den Arsch getreten wird.
Vom Arschboot.
Das war aber jetzt meine Fresse.
da wird man zumindest am Anfang gefragt, ob man
Nano oder Neovim
installieren möchte und da ich mit Nano
überhaupt nicht klarkomme,
ist natürlich Neovim drauf.
Also die Wahl zwischen Nano und Neovim
liegt zwischen einem sehr simplen Editor
und... Nalo.
Okay.
Also ich habe hier eigentlich noch so eine
Checkbox, die wir noch abhaken müssen.
Gut, Apple Vision ist jetzt vorbei.
ist durch. Aber ich hatte ja
eigentlich jetzt die Box.
Kean benutzt jetzt Firefox. Was kannst du denn
für
Firefox Extensions
empfehlen? Weil ich benutze
tatsächlich kaum welche.
Ein paar, ohne die ich generell nicht leben kann.
Natürlich U-Block Origin, weil
logisch. Ja, gut, okay, die habe ich auch.
Und dieselbe Idee nochmal
für YouTube, Sponsor-Block.
Stimmt, die habe ich auch von dir empfohlen bekommen. Die werden wir mal
alle in die Show Notes packen. Fantastisch. Ansonsten
brauche ich natürlich Tree-Style-Tab, sonst
Ich glaube, mein Setup nicht und One Password für meinen Passwort Manager.
Temper Monkey nutze ich tatsächlich gerne.
Auch auf der Arbeit habe ich ein paar Sachen über Dingskripte.
Wie sagt man dazu? User Scripts?
Temper?
Das ist einfach ein User Script über Grease Monkey oder wie heißen die Alternativen?
Ich hatte mir mal Grease Monkey angeguckt, aber was macht man damit?
Ich habe auf Arbeit ein paar Sachen darüber laufen.
Was mir am relevantesten im Kopflenk ist, wir nutzen so einen Essensanbieter.
für Mittagessen zu einer Dresdner Firma
namens Lemüse.
Das ist tatsächlich sehr lecker und sehr, sehr tolles Essen.
Aber diese Seite von denen ist schrecklich.
Die haben nur so ein WordPress E-Commerce Plugin
und die Seite ist so unglaublich langsam.
Und
manchmal, wenn man sein bestelltes Essen
doch wieder abbestellt, wenn man sich entscheidet, dann doch nicht
in den Tag ins Büro zu gehen.
Und sie haben aber keine Cancel-Möglichkeit auf der Webseite,
sondern du musst dir eine E-Mail schreiben.
Echt?
Deswegen habe ich ein Userscript am Laufen,
was mir einfach in das Bestellformular
oder in meine Bestellübersicht Cancel Buttons
einfügt. Und wenn ich dann draufklicke, ist einfach
ein Mail-to-Link, der eine E-Mail prefüllt
mit meinem Namen,
mit dem Text, also wie diese Mahlzeit
heißt und dem Datum.
Und dann brauche ich noch Absintheit.
Die liefern dir Essen ins Büro?
Die liefern Essen ins Büro.
Sehr leckeres Essen.
Dann natürlich noch so Sachen
wie Consentomatic,
dass die ganzen Cookie-Banner wegklickt oder
mit meinen Einstellungen prefüllt, also
denied und wegklickt.
Oh, sowas suche ich schon
seit einer Weile. Was ich auch
sehr relevant finde, ist noch Stop
the Madness. Das ist
an sich eine Mac-App,
weil es eigentlich eine Safari-Extension
ist und die liefert es halt über den Mac-App-Store aus,
aber der bietet auch eine Firefox-Extension
und eine
Chrome-Extension glaube ich auch. Und die Idee dahinter
ist einfach, dass du die ganzen dummen Sachen auf
Webseiten, Seiten, die Rechtsklick unterbinden,
Seiten, die Paste-in-Text-Filter unterbinden,
Seiten, die sonst was machen. Das wird alles
gekillt. Du kannst auch eine Allowlist noch führen
von Seiten, wo das zulässig ist, wie das Interface
von meinem NAS. Da will ich das rechtlich funktioniert.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen werden diese ganzen
dummen Features auf Webseiten rausgekickt,
die da aufspielen sich. Oh, du darfst
hier nichts kopieren auf der Webseite. Seid ihr doof?
In welcher Welt leben wir?
Ja, ich musste
auch neulich erst wieder DevTools aufmachen,
um irgendwo einen Text rauszukopieren
von der Seite, wo der Text aus einem Grund auf einem
Button war.
Cool.
eine Extension, die ich noch highlighten kann
die ich sehr cool finde, ist BipBot
das verlinken wir auch
in den Shownotes, das ist eine Extension von
fuck, wie heißt
Stefan, Stefan irgendwas von
ich glaube von, außer Dings
oh wow, ich kann ja richtig gut
mit den gemerkt
BipBot
liegt auf GitHub
die Idee dahinter ist, dass
viele deutsche
Newsseiten Paywalls
haben
Und diese Artikelinhalte sind aber zugänglich, wenn du Accounts bei großen deutschen Bibliotheken hast und über das Bibliothekensystem, ich glaube das ist dieses Genius, aber vielleicht ist es auch nur ein Teil davon, bin mir gerade nicht ganz sicher, kannst du darüber auch diese Artikel lesen, wenn du einen bezahlten Account bei einer Bibliothek hast.
und zum Beispiel die VÖBB aus Berlin-Brandenburg
kostet der Account 10 Euro im Jahr,
also nichts.
Und wenn du da einen Account hast
und die Financials in diese Extension einträgst
und auf eine Seite gehst,
spiegel.de, keine Ahnung,
und da ist eine Paywall,
dann schaut die Extension im Hintergrund
über das Bibliotheksportal,
ob sie den Artikel findet
und falls ja,
substitutet die dann einfach an die Seite rein.
Das klappt sehr gut auf sehr vielen Seiten.
Und ich meine,
es gibt auch andere Möglichkeiten,
Paywalls zu umgehen,
da gibt es vielleicht auch Möglichkeiten,
auch für User-Skripte, für die
DNN zum Beispiel. Aber
das ist halt, das finde ich auch schön,
weil das halt auch die Bibliotheken mit supportet.
Das finde ich gut. Bibliotheken gehören
supportet.
Das sind so die wichtigsten Sachen, die ich installiert
habe. Nice.
Nice. Ja, TreeStyle hat ja
wie gesagt, die auch installiert und deaktiviert,
weil ich es irgendwie persönlich nicht so schön
finde. Es hat auch verschiedene Themes,
die alle schrecklich hässlich sind, bis auf eins
ist es brauchbar. Ja, die Themes,
also ich weiß nicht, was Sie sich dabei denken.
Nee, ich meine die Threestyle-Tapper-Themes.
Ach so.
Also es gibt noch die Browser-Themes,
das ist auch nicht meine Welt, das wäre vielleicht meine Welt gewesen
vor 15 Jahren, aber...
Nee.
Ich weiß noch, als ich damals, vor Ewigkeiten,
vor wahrscheinlich 15 Jahren, Chrome installiert habe,
weil Chrome gerade rauskam.
Und das war eine Revelation,
wie schnell dieser neue Browser war.
Und dieses Bild vor Augen
von diesem Browser mit der blauen Leiste oben,
das fühlt sich heute noch flott an,
Dieses Gefühl.
Ich habe aber auch manchmal den Eindruck, wenn ich so Anwendungen sehe, die so ein bisschen altes Windows-eskes UI haben.
So richtige Software hat Bevels.
Das finde ich stark.
Da habe ich immer noch den Eindruck, das ist was solideres.
Das ist wahrscheinlich was absolut furchtbares, weil die Software-Praktiken von vor 20 Jahren absolut bescheiden waren.
das alles in C geschrieben ist und ständig
abstürzt oder an Speicherstellen schreibt,
die es nicht soll. Aber irgendwie
habe ich, wenn ich das nur sehe, schon
einen besseren Eindruck
davon.
Kann ich da einen Pick
von mir vorgreifen? Bitte.
Weil der passt gerade sehr gut dazu.
Das ist ein
GTK XFCE-Theme
Chicago.
Chicago 95.
Das sieht so schön aus.
Also es gibt schon viele Windows 95 Themes für Linux-Desktops, aber wenn das wirklich so aussieht...
Das ist als Total Conversion gedacht und es geht echt weit und es sieht fantastisch aus.
Und ich war auf Hacker News vor ein paar Tagen und die Kommentare waren auch alle so,
also haben ein paar Leute geschrieben und es hat mich voll irgendwie resonatet in meinem Kopf,
wie snappy das aussieht und dann haben Leute darunter geantwortet,
Deine Erinnerung ist einfach so getrübt.
Also natürlich war das nicht snappy.
Damals hatten wir noch Spinning-Hard-Disks,
super langsam und alles war einfach
dreckslangsam. Du hast Dinge geöffnet, es hat
fünf Minuten gefühlt gedauert, bis ein Fenster da war.
Aber das stimmt auch total.
Das war damals dreckslangsam.
Aber in meiner Erinnerung ist das auch so snappy.
Und ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt.
Vielleicht, wenn man irgendwann eine VM in der Hand hatte und die war
drecksnappy, aber
es fühlt sich effizient an.
Und ich finde es schon geil, dass das Rechner
nur erstmal so aussah.
Windows 95 ist schon so Peak Design.
Windows 95 war
übrigens
die, ich nenne es mal
das Desktop Environment,
was das X als Close Button
established hat.
Ich schmeiße es mal
in unsere Show Notes. Und zwar gab es
natürlich im Zuge dieser
Twitter-nach-Shitter-Umbenennung
einen Artikel
auf
Medium, der
dann auf Hackernos rumgegangen ist.
Vielleicht habt ihr den schon gelesen, aber X to Close.
The origins of the use of X in UI-Design.
X is everywhere in User Interfaces.
The powerful symbol X, the capital X for closing windows and pop-ups and toolbars and tabs
and anything else that might otherwise be cluttering on your screen.
Und ein paar Beispiele wie überall hier, Close Button in Windows, Tabs von Chrome, überall gibt es X.
Aber, das war nicht immer so.
Jetzt hier eine schöne History von,
wie sah das früher aus? Windows 1.0
hatte kein X.
Windows 2.0 hatte kein X.
Da gab es diese geilen,
fetten Hoch-
und Runterpfeile.
So ein Page-Up- und Page-Down-Button in der Ecke vom Fenster, rechts oben.
Genau. Links ist wie so ein Minimieren-Button in Minus.
Ja, aber ich weiß gar nicht, was der gemacht hat.
Aber heißt Minimieren vielleicht einfach schließen in dem Kontext?
Also weg,
Minus ist ein Fenster weniger.
Klicke auf das Minus.
Ich musste mich übrigens, einer meiner Hauptkritikpunkte
an macOS ist, dass sie das Konzept von
ich schließe eine App komplett
ad absurdum führen.
Ja gut, also das ist halt
Windows 3.0 hatte auch
kein X, das hier ist dir vielleicht bekannt,
da hat er so ein runterzeigendes schwarzes
Dreieck. Aber ich meine, andere Fenster haben
hoch. Also ich, also
genau, hoch, es gibt hoch, runter, maximieren
und ausmachen.
Ich glaube, die Systeme konnten einfach nicht.
Multitasking war halt auch noch nicht, oder?
Es gab, also die Digger konnten schon
Aber wenn du die App nicht mehr gebraucht hast, dann hast du sie einfach geschlossen.
Wie man es halt macht.
Macht man ja heute auch. Also der Browser ist halt ein extra OS, was du für immer offen heißt.
Genau. Das ist eine virtuelle Maschine, die da drin ist.
Die das Web für dich ausführt. Das Google-Betriebssystem.
Fuck ja.
Und dann gab es mit Windows 95 das erste Mal das X oben.
Und hier wird nochmal aufgezählt, es gab Screenshots.
Da gab es, das ist ja ein früherer Screenshot von Windows 95.
das war Windows 93,
Windows Chicago hieß das übrigens als
Vorgeschichte, da kommt das her.
Und das hat noch leicht andere
Icons. Und da ist auch dieses Startbutton,
da steht noch nicht Start, sondern das ist
nur das alte Windows-Logo.
Und danach ist es,
bei macOS gab es dann immer noch keins,
bei macOS 2 gab es kein Closebutton.
Auch
selbst bei X gab es kein Closebutton.
Ich scrolle hier, also ihr könnt, wenn ihr die Seite gleichzeitig aufmacht,
ich scrolle hier einfach diese Bilder da rein.
Aber natürlich hat X kein X als Closebutton.
Pterox hat kein X, obwohl da überall X im Namen zweimal vorkam.
Und erst irgendwann war dann das erste,
hier gibt es noch ganz viele andere Desktop-User-Interfaces,
die ich noch nie gehört habe, Atari TOS hatte...
Hatte ein X.
Naja, nee, das ist eher so eine Art...
Ach, der hat ja da links, ja.
Dementschließend-Button.
What? Nachahmer.
So, PlayStation-Controller hat X.
Hier geht es noch auf Geschichte ein von der Bedeutung von Kreisen und Kreuzen aus dem japanischen Kontext.
Also Controller sind ja auch so witzig.
Du hast ja, da gibt es ja diesen Krieg in Anführungszeichen, dass du auf Nintendo-Controllern rechts bestätigst und unten zurückdrückst.
Fuck, habe ich das umgedreht?
Nee, genau, rechts bestätigen.
A, B, fuck.
Da oben liegt so ein Controller.
Ja, genau.
Ja, alles richtig gesagt.
Rechts bestätigen und unten ist Cancel quasi.
A und B. Und auf
westlichen Controllern ist das immer genau andersrum.
Da ist unten bestätigen und rechts
cancel. Deswegen komme ich nie auf diese Geräte klar.
Und die switchen das halt. Und wenn du halt häufig zwischen diesen beiden
Plattformen hin und her switchst, macht das total
in Kirche. Das ist wie wenn du die ganze Zeit zwischen
einem deutschen und einem US-Layout hin und her switchst und
mit den Technologen durcheinander kommst.
Die überweil nicht so relevant sind. Genau. Next Computer,
die 1988 rauskam,
hatten übrigens, oh, hatten
einen X. Ich muss es
zurücknehmen. Windows 95 war nicht
die ersten.
Und seit wann hat
macOS ein X?
Seit wahrscheinlich macOS 9 oder 10?
Seitdem sie Next gekauft haben und
das alles Next basiert war dann vermutlich.
Achso, stimmt, wir haben ja einfach, also
Next ist ja einfach
macOS 10 gewesen.
Naja, ich glaube so einfach, kannst du das nicht sagen.
Da wird der Helge jetzt
drüber aufregen, dass wir
die Story nicht
richtig hinkriegen. Aber
die haben ja Next damals
Also sie haben ja Steve rausgeschmissen, Steve Jobs,
der dann
fuck, hat er Next
er hat Next irgendwie mitgegründet
oder sowas da war. Und dann haben sie Next
ein paar Jahre später wieder aufgekauft und wieder
ins Boot geholt.
Ja, als Apple zu sehr runtergegangen ist.
Aber es ist ja alles Next basiert.
Also alles, was wir an modernen Apple-Systemen haben, ist Next basiert.
Deswegen hast du die ganzen Next-Step-Klassen
noch mit drin. Es ist ja alles NS.
Ja, das ist immer dieser komische
Kontext in Deutschland.
Ja, soviel zur Geschichte von X in User Interfaces.
Weil das übrigens gerade ein Medium-Link ist, den du geöffnet hattest.
Diese Firefox-Sendation, die ich vorhin angesprochen habe, LibRedirect,
die redirectet auch Medium-Artikel auf Scribe.
Scribe ist ein offener Alternativ-Client für Medium,
damit du keine scheiß Medium nutzen musst,
was 20-mal schneller als Medium läuft.
Das ist ein Client für Medium.
Also ein Frontend-Client. Das ist eine Webseite,
so wie ein Nitter für ein Twitter-Client ist.
Das klingt immer, ich habe mal ein
alternatives
Frontend für Tagesschau.
Ja, ich weiß schon mal, wie schnell das geladen hat.
Das ist eine Medium-Seite, die halt einfach da ist.
Und ich kann scrollen,
die Bilder sind alle da und müssen nicht nachladen.
Achso, das ist ja ein Feature, dass die Bilder
erst dann laden, wenn du dorthin lernst.
Du machst das Tab auf,
dann musst du los,
nimmst dein Laptop mit, dann machst du den Zug wieder auf.
Ja toll, Grafiken kannst du heute nicht.
Naja, es gibt so viele
Medium-Posts, wie man das optimieren
kann, dass er, je nachdem, was du
für eine Auflösung hast, nur die Bilder runterlädt,
die für dein System
gerade die ideale Größe haben.
Das mag ja sein, aber ich will
trotzdem das alles geladen werden, wenn ich die Seite aufmache.
Ich will
idealerweise natürlich auch schnell laden.
Du darfst gerne die
Vorschaubilder als erstes laden und dann aber,
sobald das kann, die anderen.
Da gibt es ja auch dieses coole Konzept, was wir
in manchen Matrix-Clients mit nutzen.
wie heißt Blur-Hashes, dass du
Bilder...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie funktionieren denn diese Algorithmen,
die diese
wunderschönen, verblurrten
Vorschau-Bilder zeigen, wenn du ein Bild nicht laden kannst, oder?
Genau, da ist das zur einen Implementierung.
Also wie genau das im Detail technisch funktioniert,
kann ich dir nicht sagen, weil ich nicht so viel Ahnung von
Grafik habe. Aber Blur-Hash
ist ein Ansatz dafür und dann
kriegst du halt einen kurzen, ich glaube
Base64-String, wenn mich nicht täuscht.
Blur-Hash.
Aber sehr, sehr kurz und den kannst du halt mit deiner API
Response schon ausliefern.
Und dann hast du halt ein
Preview, während du das
... Nee, ist kein Base64.
Das ist Sydney, das ist aber auch ein String.
Aber du kannst
das wieder dekodieren aus einem Bild, aus einem sehr geblurten
Bild. Ach, das ist
prozedural erzeugt quasi, aus
einem String? Genau.
Und dann machst du halt ein Bild aus diesem String, weil du
den halt in deiner API Response schon kriegst.
Und den hast du zum Beispiel auch in einer Matrix Message mit drin,
wenn du halt einen Supported Client hast.
Das ist ein Wort.
Blur Hash, vielleicht findest du es so besser auf Quids.
Ich muss immer erstmal schauen,
hat das schon jemand in Rust geschrieben?
Ja, 100 Uhr.
Ah, nicht Hash, Hash.
Blur Hash, aber
Pure Rust Implementation of Blur Hash.
Fast Blur Hash, Blur Hash,
NG Blur Hash, Fast Blur Hash
CLI Blur Hash,
okay, es gibt genug Implementierung
von Blur Hash.
Aber an sich halt eine super coole Idee, weil so
zeigst du halt nicht einfach nur so eine hässliche UI an.
Ist halt immer die Frage, wie schnell kriegst du es.
dass es so klein geht. Ich dachte, das ist irgendein
Vorschaubild, irgendwie
auf Pixel basierendes.
Dann müsstest du ja trotzdem ein Thumbnail ausliefern.
Und ein Thumbnail kannst du nicht direkt zusammen mit deiner
Response schicken, weil du das halt
embedden müsstest wahrscheinlich mit als URL,
oder du Base64 encodest das Thumbnail.
Du kannst es als Data irgendwie als...
Ja, aber dann ist es halt wieder fetter.
Und das ist halt wirklich hier ein 20-Zeichen-String gewesen.
Ja, wie gesagt,
du kannst ja auch einen 20-Zeichen-Pixels
wahrscheinlich, wer weiß vielleicht...
Touché, ja.
Wer weiß, worauf das passiert ist.
Ich müsste es mir mal angucken.
Das finde ich cool.
Es ist schön, wenn man zu diesen Konzepten,
die man regelmäßig sieht,
auch selbst bei technischen Sachen, die man ja regelmäßig macht,
endlich mal den Begriff dazu weiß,
was dahinter steht.
Ich finde es auch einen coolen Namen dafür, muss ich sagen.
Blur Hash.
Du hast ein Bild,
zu einem geblurten Bild runter.
Finde ich gut.
Scribe für Medium.
Wieder was gelernt.
Ich glaube, scribe.rip ist die Domain von dem Tool selber.
Aber ich mag diese Extension einfach,
weil es ein paar Seiten gibt.
Also ich habe auch nicht,
du kannst da richtig viel konfigurieren.
Ich hätte ja, wenn ich irgendwie eine Alternative
zu Medium anbieten würde,
hätte ich mir, glaube ich,
einen anderen Pun ausgedacht irgendwie.
Das Ding kann richtig viele Sachen.
Das kann Reddit, das kann TikTok,
YouTube, Fandom, IMDB, GitHub, Wayback Machine.
Da gibt es überall alternative Frontends für.
Und ich nutze das nur für Twitter.
Also das macht, was du mir jetzt zeigst,
ist jetzt gerade irgendeine Firefox-Extension?
Genau, genau. Und es ist nicht Scribe, sondern...
Nee, nee, die kann aber Medium auf Scribe
und du hast auch noch die Möglichkeit, noch andere Sachen zu können.
Genau, es gibt auch Lib Medium.
Du musst bitte alle deine Firefox-Extensions in die Shownotes tun.
Und Urban Dictionary, gehe ich auf Rural Dictionary,
weil Urban Dictionary auch dreckslangsam ist
und nicht nur so sehr sehr häufig.
Es gibt hier Wikipedia, aber selbst Wikipedia,
die Webseite verändert sich in den letzten Jahren
immer mal, so alle paar Jahre.
Heute habe ich immer wieder irgendwas
auf Wikipedia gelesen und mir gedacht,
Mensch, ist hier doch was passiert.
Ich mag, dass das englische Frontend für Wikipedia
mehr ist als deutsche,
weil es ein paar coole Designanpassungen drin hat.
Genau, das kannst du irgendwie die Breite anpassen.
Aber es ist ja auch, also meine Lieblingsänderung
generell auf der Wikipedia ist vor ein paar Jahren gewesen,
dass die diesen Inline-Image-Viewer haben,
dass du auf ein Bild klickst und das lädt Vollbild-Inline.
Du gehst dich direkt weitergeleitet auf Wikimedia.
Und dann kannst du halt überklicken mit dem X-Knopf in der Ecke.
Das ist letztens tatsächlich auch passiert,
als ich einen Twitter-Link tatsächlich noch offen hatte.
Und dann hat man auf das X-Klick.
ich fühle mich wie so ein Boomer so
oh Gott ist mir das gerade wirklich passiert
naja es kommt ja noch dazu dass du bei den
Systemen, witzigerweise
bei macOS ist das
schließen und diese
Window Decoration Buttons sind oben links
ja außer bei
Tabs, da sind sie wieder rechts
das ist eigentlich
inkonsistent
ich weiß nicht ob die Richtung da so als ob man
alle Buttons auf der linken Seite vom Bildschirm
erwarten würde
oder auf der linken Kante von Elementen
Es ist halt, naja, vielleicht
waren es die Briten, die sind schuld.
Ja, die fahren ja auch auf der falschen
Nordenstraße. Eben, es gibt die linke
Seite und es gibt the right side.
The correct side.
Ah, ich würde jetzt
sehr vorsichtig sein, alles was rechts heißt,
dann plötzlich mit dem rechten.
Du hast mir
irgendwann mal einen Strick draus gedreht
auf damals noch Twitter,
als ich irgendwie über Bananen geschrieben
habe und irgendwie
geschrieben habe, es gibt nicht viele
gute braune Sachen, aber braune Bananen
sind um mich die besten Bananen.
Du weißt schon, dass das ganz rassistisch ist,
was du gerade schreibst.
Alter, das war doch überhaupt nicht...
Oh Gott, nein, jetzt muss ich diesen Tweet löschen.
Scheiße.
Oh Gott.
Bei mir im Büro
ist es übrigens so, dass es
in den einzelnen kleinen Kaffeeküchen
Obst gibt,
was ich total appreciate.
Es wird montags immer geliefert.
Da werden auch Bananen geliefert unter anderem. Allgemein ist jedwödes Obst, was da Montag geliefert wird, erst Mittwoch oder Donnerstag essbar.
Das stimmt nicht. Bananen sind lecker, wenn sie grün sind.
Und dadurch, dass eh bei uns im Büro so ein bisschen Flaute an Mitarbeitern herrscht, weil einfach jeder von zu Hause arbeitet, bleiben total viele Bananen über und dann ist unsere gute Seele geht freitags immer rum und sammelt die ganzen Bananen ein und legt die in unserer Hauptküche.
Dann auf so ein Tablett, da gibt es so ein riesiges Tablett mit reifen Bananen und ich denke mir so, oh schon wieder.
Du bist auch in der Fraktion, Bananen müssen unreif sein, damit sie schmecken.
Ja, die dürfen nicht so süß sein.
Die müssen noch einen Hauch bitter sein.
Du meinst sauer.
Ja, also wenn die genau
diese perfekte Färbung zwischen grün und gelb haben.
Also bevor sie komplett gelb sind,
noch so ein Hauch von grün, das ist die perfekte Banane.
Also ich finde, für meinen Geschmack
dürfen Bananen schon so ein bisschen wie dein Unterarm aussehen.
Fleckig.
Mit Zommersprossen.
Genau.
Schön, okay.
Weil dann sind sie, ich mag sie ja eher süß.
Das wäre auch komisch.
folgend hätte, aber okay.
Aber zumindest, wenn ich
eine Alternative für Medium
gesucht hätte, wäre nicht mehr schon
ein anderes Pun überlegt.
Statt Medium gibt es halt
Hard oder Soft
oder so was. Oder Good.
Oder Rare. Medium and Rare.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist wahr.
Well done.
Wenn es nicht Medium ist,
dann ist es well done.
Das ist eine gute Domain, ja.
Ja, gibt es wahrscheinlich schon.
Gibt es
welldo.ne
noch nicht?
Gibt es überhaupt?
NL haben die Niederlande.
Nick.ne
Wer weiß, ob das eine NL ist.
Ich glaube, NL-Domains gibt es nicht.
Das wäre lustig.
Johannes hat sich heute
eine neue Domain gekauft.
Drowning.lol
Ach nein.
Warum?
Weil das dieses typische Schild ist.
See someone drowning.
Wenn so eine politisierte Person die die Arme in die Luft hält,
aber aussieht wie LOL.
See someone drowning.
Das ist so bitter.
Aber es stimmt, ich hab da als erstes
LOL gelesen.
See someone drowning.
Aber gibt's nicht
Unicode?
Ja, also manche TLDs können das.
Nicht alle.
Aber.GA zum Beispiel kann das.
Deswegen kannst du mal auf
penguinemoji.gr gehen.
Rettungsring.lol
Wow.
Die würde ich mir ja kaufen.
Vielleicht muss ich mir die jetzt kaufen.
Ich mag auch PunyCode.
PunyCode sieht so hässlich aus.
Aber ich muss mir jetzt diese Domain kaufen.
Rettungsring.lol
Ich weiß nicht, ob.lol
mit Emoji klarkommt.
Das musst du rausfinden.
Punkt.
Lol.
Es ist immer herrlich, wenn du.lol-Domains
mit ernsten Themen
verheiratest. Also gerade
drowning.lol
würde ich sagen, setzt dem Ganzen so die Krone auf.
Ich weiß nicht, was man damit macht.
Bekannter von uns,
TheBlitz, der eigentlich
sehr viel wissenschaftlich über
Prozessorenarchitekturen
schreibt und arbeitet,
hat sich x86.lol
für seinen Blog gesichert.
Das ist ja auch eine starke Domain.
86, nicht 68.
Oh, ups.
Kann ich tippen?
Genau. Ach, schön. Das ist eine schöne Domain.
Genau.
Was habt ihr denn für schöne Domains?
Schreibt uns doch mal in unseren Matrix-Channel,
was ihr für schöne Domains gesichert habt.
Apropos, wir haben
einen neuen Feedback-Channel.
Nein!
Wir haben eine neue Webseite.
Was?
Akronomisier.lol
Das wäre jetzt stark gewesen.
Aber nein, wir sind nach wie vor
akkonomisier.bar.
Aber wir haben
die Webseite geändert. Also zum
Zeitpunkt des Aufnehmens ist sie
noch auf next.akkonomisier.bar.
Aber zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung dieser Folge
wird die da sein.
Die ist sehr viel minimalistischer
als die Seite davor. Dafür ist sie
selbst gehostet und selbst gebastelt.
Mit sehr viel Liebe.
Und ich finde es auch, ehrlich gesagt, technisch eigentlich ganz
cool, was dahinter steckt.
Dass halt unser
die Source of Truth ist keine
statisch generierte Seite, das ist eine
dynamische Seite. Jetzt flex mal
Kilian, erzähl, was dahinter steckt.
Es ist halt auch recht simpel, aber
also wenn du im JavaScript im Browser deaktiviert
hast, wird die Seite auch nicht laden, das ist natürlich
ein bisschen sad, aber es ist
eine React App, sagen wir es so.
Was aber die Idee dahinter
ist, ist, dass unser
RSS-Feed unsere Source of Truth ist
und die React App lädt halt direkt
beim Request der Seite den
RSS-Feed und
vendort den quasi als Sited.
Gut, das könnte man auch, das hast du direkt mit angesprochen gehabt,
über sowas wie XSLT lösen,
dass man das ganz klassisch
macht, was ich auch ehrlich gesagt immer noch
eine sehr coole Idee finde, es ist bloß viel beschissener
zu maintain, ich habe gar kein Bock drauf.
Gibt es vielleicht irgendwelche Tools?
Das müssen wir uns mal nochmal angucken.
Aber du bist ja jetzt React-Entwickler
und deswegen musstest du dir gleich erstmal
die Finger schmutzig machen. Das hat Spaß gemacht,
die Seite zu bauen. Wir haben auch Detailseiten für jede
für jede Folge. Wir haben einen Player
da direkt mit drin, der sogar Chapter Marks mit kann.
Und da kannst du sogar anklicken, die Chapter Marks,
und dann springt der im Player vor.
Und die Shownotes sind da schick angezeigt.
Wir haben eine Folgensuche,
die sogar in den Shownotes
der Folge mit sucht, auch wenn du den dort nicht sehen kannst.
Also es funktioniert alles ganz cool
und mir hat bloß der Gedanke ein bisschen
missfallen, dass du die Seite an sich
nicht maschinenlesbar lesen kannst.
Aber
dafür ist ja der Feed da.
Der Feed ist eh viel maschinendesbarer als eine HTML-Seite
und die Seite liest dasselbe wie den Feed.
Eben. Aber jetzt ist das ein bisschen repetitiv
hier mit unserem Logo an jeder Folge.
Wir müssen mal mehr Episodenfoto machen.
Wir haben genau zwei Folgen mit Custom Cover.
Genau. Einmal vom...
Das Holiday Special.
Es waren mehr. Das hier mit dem
Passwort. Das war's.
Das war's.
Mehr Folgen mit Custom Cover haben wir nicht.
Oh, wir müssen gleich ein Foto zusammen aufnehmen.
Machen wir diese Folge mit einem Custom Cover?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Hallo, ich mach gleich mal hier.
Machst du es ja just in diesem Moment.
Just in diesem Moment, ach ne, warte mal, da ist ja meine Wohnung mit drauf,
da muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen, dass man nicht zu viel von meiner Wohnung sieht.
Hi!
Aber kontinuiert, ganz ehrlich.
Wir sind so der Inbegriff von privilegierte Nerds,
die langweilig ist und die einen Podcast machen, oder?
Ich habe richtig häufig diesen von wegen Lisbeth-Titel im Kopf.
Du warst ja mal auf den Konzerten, hast mir den Titel geschickt gehabt,
weil du den gerade live gehört hast.
Also, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, muss ich sagen,
ich habe eine gewisse Sinnkrise bekommen.
Und von wegen Leasebet sind unter anderem
mit dafür verantwortlich, dass wir anderthalb Jahre
keine neue Folge rausgebracht haben.
Wir verlinken auch in den Journals,
den verlinkt man in den Song.
Ob Spotify-Link
oder so was, oder YouTube-Link?
Was ist denn die offene Song-
Verlinkungsplattform?
Wir müssen Spotify-Link
einen Apple Music-Link.
Gibt es Napster noch?
Bandcamp wäre cool,
aber ich glaube kaum, dass die da auf Bandcamp sind.
Soundcloud? Nee, ist ja auch
Quatsch. Keine Ahnung.
Für Linken, wenn wir es noch hinschreiben,
der Titel heißt Podcast, glaube ich, oder?
Genau.
Und er hat einen herrlichen Text.
Vor allem, wenn man den geschickt bekommt
von seinem Podcast-Coast.
Ja, das sind so Bands,
die auch so schöne Titel hat, wie
Elon Musk kam nicht ins Berghain
und
ein anderer.
Oh, by the way,
nicht komplett anderes Thema,
leicht related, meine Lieblingsband
macht ein Konzert in Berlin im Oktober.
Systemabsturz.
Und die Tickets sind sehr
billig gewesen.
Du hast gleich zehn gekauft.
Nur zwei. Aber
ich weiß nicht, ob es noch welche gibt,
wenn du Bock hast. Also ich fahre definitiv hin.
Dann kannst du mir gleich mal nach der Sendung
noch einen Link dazugeben.
Ja, also wir haben eine neue Seite,
schaut sie euch an.
Und wie wir darauf gekommen sind,
weil es lustig ist, hat auch jede Folge
unten drunter einfach noch eine Kommentar-Section,
die aber dynamisch aus GitHub geladen wird.
Über GitHub-Discussions läuft das Ganze.
Das heißt, es gibt auch
Replies.
Die Leute schreiben
mit ihrem GitHub
Genau, das GitHub-Oarth, um dich anzumelden.
Weil wahrscheinlich
99% unserer Hörer GitHub-Accounts.
Wahrscheinlich.
GitHub ist so, dass...
Ich muss sagen, ich habe irgendwie aus irgendeinem Grund Twitter und GitHub lange Zeit equated, weil ich irgendwie der ähnlicher Crowd folge irgendwie auf beiden.
Und GitHub ist ja so ein bisschen ein Social Network.
Und ich habe mir jedes Mal gedacht, ach wie fies wäre es jetzt, wenn GitHub von so einer Heuschrecke gekauft werden würde und der würde da so Mist bauen.
Und dann ist mir eingefallen, oh GitHub ist ja von Microsoft.
Aber man muss ihnen zugutehalten, es ist noch nicht so viel Schlimmes bei GitHub passiert, seitdem die von Microsoft gekauft wurden.
oder kannst du mir jetzt all die Geschichten erzählen,
die ich ausgeblendet habe und ich bin
hinterher ganz traurig.
Na, offen Schlimmes ist nichts passiert.
Sie haben den...
Hm.
Das könnt ihr uns in die Kommentare schreiben,
auf unserer schönen GitHub-basierten Kommentarfunktion,
die wir jetzt haben.
Die ganze Kacke mit Eis war ja vorher schon.
Ja, es ist auch
Palantir-Code immer noch auf GitHub,
soweit ich das weiß.
Ich meine, jetzt musst du halt damit leben,
dass Microsoft Zugriff auf deine privaten Repos hat.
Aber ich meine, davor war es GitHub.
Das machst du nicht besser.
Also wenn du deine privaten Repos in die Cloud legst
zu einer privaten Firma,
dann musst du damit leben,
dass die Zugriff darauf haben.
Oh, wow.
Aber das ist halt schon schlimmer,
wenn das Microsoft ist,
weil Microsoft eine schreckliche, schreckliche Firma ist.
Kennst du übrigens diese GitHub-Features,
dass man einfach auf ein Profil gehen kann
und Dateiendung hinten ran schreibt?
Und dann kriegt man das Bild von der Person geladen,
die da drin steht.
Ich meine, dass man über den Avatar reinkommt,
das ergibt Sinn, aber ich habe nicht dran gedacht,
ich kannte das nur für die SSH-Keys.
Die SSH-Keys?
Wenn du Punkt Keys drin schreibst.
Ich habe nämlich gestern noch rumgespielt
und hatte noch ein Ubuntu per UTM
auf meinem Laptop installiert.
Und da wirst du tatsächlich beim Installieren gefragt,
möchtest du SSH-Keys,
wenn du Ubuntu-Server installierst,
möchtest du hier irgendwelche SSH-Keys
zum Traflocken bereits installieren?
Und kannst du von GitHub importieren? Gib mir uns doch mal
deinen GitHub-User-Name.
Das sind meine Public-SSH-Keys.
Wenn irgendein System diese Dinger hier
hinterlegt, kann ich mich da einloggen.
Ich habe das schon häufig genutzt, auch für fremde Leute, um den Zugriff
auf den Server zu geben, nämlich einfach deren GitHub-Account
direkt pipel, also den Curl davon
direkt pipel in die Authorized Keys rein.
Ja, stimmt.
Aber dass die Software
irgendwo direkt das als Feature so implementiert,
dass du nicht mal mehr deinen Key reinpastest als Text,
sondern einfach deinen GitHub-Handle eingibst,
finde ich witzig.
Im Endeffekt ist das hier
SSH GitHub OAuth.
Du möchtest dich einloggen?
Wie heißt du denn?
Kilian Kö. Okay, du kommst rein.
Es ist halt echt eine coole Authentication,
weil ich habe wahrscheinlich diese Keys lokal
bei mir, die privaten Keys dazu
und das läuft dann einfach.
Das ist eigentlich, wie hieß dieser
Open SS,
wie hieß dieser GPG?
Ja, Keybase.
Die wurden von Zoom gekauft damals.
Das fühlt sich auch so surreal an.
Die hatten encrypted Repos.
Ich hatte meine Steuerdokumente
alle in dem Git-Repo bei Keybase liegen,
weil es verschlüsselt war und weil es eh
scheißegal war. Also meine Steuerdokumente.
Ich hab die einfach irgendwo in die Repo mal geschmissen, weil ich das
in Zusammenfassung, weil das sinnvoll fand,
aber irgendwie ist das ja auch Quatsch.
Dafür gibt's
EncFS.
Benutzt du das noch?
Das hab ich schon so lange nicht mehr benutzt, dass ich gar nicht
weiß, ob das auf Mac überhaupt funktioniert.
EncFS mountet hier ein
verschlüsseltes Fuse-Datei
System. Funktionieren Fuse-Datel-Systeme
auf Mac OS? Ich glaube schon.
Ja? Also. Ein Kaffee.
So, jetzt haben wir schon so
viel Zeug angeteasert. Wollen wir überhaupt noch auf
PIX eingehen oder wollen wir es sein lassen?
Es gibt hier noch einen
Link in unseren Themen.
Zwei.
Wollen wir die noch mit reinnehmen?
Und zwar
der erste ist, are we
MLS yet?
Das musst du mir jetzt sagen, was das bedeutet.
Das ist von
von den Matrix-Leuten.
Und die Idee ist, MLS ist
Message Layer Security.
Dieses neue Proposal,
meine ich,
ich habe nur mitverfolgt ein bisschen am Rande,
habe mich nicht tief mit der Thematik auseinandergesetzt.
Das ist dieses Proposal von
der EU, was die haben wollen für
Interoperability von Messengern.
Und das ist MLS.
Ich kann dir aber technisch absolut gar nichts zu MLS
sagen.
Ich weiß nur, dass die Idee ist, dass du halt auch,
also dass du nirgendwo diese Probleme hast,
die ich mit Beeper zum Beispiel habe, wo du halt
Endless is now in RFC.
Wo du quasi
End-to-Bridge-Encryption hast
und dann
Bridge-to-End-Encryption auf der anderen Seite wieder,
aber deine Bridge das halt aufmachen muss.
Und MMS hat dieses Problem,
also soll das halt nicht haben. Du willst halt
an sich von einem Service mit einem anderen Service
komplett verschlüsselt von End-to-End reden können.
Weil die sich die Krypto-Stacks
teilen oder beziehungsweise auf derselben Basis
aufbauen. Und
die Matrix-Leute saßen da auch mit am Tisch für.
Das fand ich sehr, sehr cool, auch zusammen mit anderen großen
Playern wie Meta und ich vermute
auch Apple und anderen Sachen.
Aber ich weiß gerade gar nicht, wer da am Tisch saß.
Und
die haben halt diese Seite ins Leben gerufen,
AboiMLS jetzt, wo sie schauen,
dass sie Matrix auch auf das Level
hosten, dass Matrix direkt MLS
spricht. Und ich weiß nicht genau, was
das heißt, ob das heißt, dass sie
jetzt wollte ich schon OTR sagen, lol,
dass sie
MacAlm rausschmeißen werden oder ob das überhaupt
MacAlm ersetzt, aber es hat wohl auch einige
coole Features und ist wohl auch sehr effizient
für große Gruppen.
Na, Olm wird hier sogar direkt
referenziert.
Wetter Performance for Large Rooms,
dann Olm oder Mecholm. Ach ja, Mecholm.
M-E-G-Olm. Genau, Mecholm
steht für Mega-Olm, also
für Olm für große Räume.
Olm ist ja das Ding, was von Open Whisper
Systems damals von den Signal-Leuten ins Leben
gerufen wurde. Ja, das ist das alte Axolotl.
Genau, das neue Axolotl.
Axolotl ist schon noch ein cooler Name.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Das blöde Feature an Olm ist ja,
dass es auf 256 Raumteilnehmer limitiert ist.
Das ist halt ein Hard Limit von Olm.
Also in Single kannst du keine Gruppen haben,
die größer als 256 Leute groß sind.
Das ist schon ein bisschen Arbitrier,
aber da haben sie wahrscheinlich irgendwo eine Bitmaske,
die nur so und so groß ist.
Vermutlich.
Ich vermute mal nicht,
dass die Arbitrier dieses Limit gewählt haben
und sich vor allem dann auch halten fest dran.
Und Mac-Olm ist halt einfach quasi ohne dieses Limit,
also dieselbe Idee,
funktioniert auf dieselbe Art und Weise,
Olm, aber ist halt optimiert auf,
dass du halt größere Räume haben kannst.
Weil das dem Matrix-Leuten sehr viel wichtiger war,
dass sie nicht nur DMs nutzen,
sondern auch sehr große Räume,
verschlüsselte Räume haben können.
Und MMS hat halt dieses Feature auch gleich mit abgedeckt.
Also du kannst große Gruppen damit verschlüsseln,
sagen wir das so.
Aber sonst kann ich dir technisch leider gar nichts wirklich zu sagen.
Also das wäre eigentlich mal ein schönes Thema
für eine Sonderfolge,
falls sich jemand von unseren Hörern damit auskennt
oder vielleicht falls ihr jemanden empfehlen könnt,
den wir dazu interviewen können.
Das wäre cool.
Das würde ich gerne mal machen.
Ich habe, das kann ich hier mal kurz antisen,
Ich habe nicht die Hauptarbeit gemacht, ich habe sogar sehr wenig dran gemacht, aber ein Kollege von mir, der Tobi, hat in unserer Open Source Org das hier als während der Arbeit entwickelt.
CureFrame RS
veröffentlicht.
Und zwar hat mich jetzt, was du gerade
über MLS erzählt hast,
sehr an S-Frame erinnert.
Und zwar ist S-Frame ein
IETF-Draft
für
frame-basierte
Verschlüsselung für
Web-EIC.
Okay, das ist für euch sehr relevant.
Und das, genau,
da haben wir
eine Implementierung
auf GitHub und auf
Create.io, die, haha, wie war die ersten?
S-Frame heißt. Jetzt gibt es von den Leuten,
die aktiv an der Spec hauptsächlich
arbeiten, auch eine Referenzimplementierung in
Rust. Die kriegen den Namen jetzt nicht.
Sad.
Vielleicht habe ich
das irgendwann am Rande schon mal erwähnt.
Das wäre schön, das mal zu vergleichen untereinander.
Bei S-Frame ist es so, dass du
quasi nur den, dass du
zwar weiterhin Video oder Audio streamen
kannst, aber nur die
eigentlichen Payload-Daten verschlüsselst und
so was wie Frame und Paket-Header, wodurch du es weiterhin über Video- und Audio-Forwarding-Infrastruktur leiten kannst.
Also es gibt so was, in der Web-Ads-Welt gibt es so was wie SFUs, das sind Selective Forwarding-Units, wenn wir in einer Videokonferenz sind.
Ja, dann entscheidet die, der Hendrik redet gerade, ich leite mal nur Pakete von Hendrik an alle weiter.
Und dazu muss man aber gewisse Sachen über die Pakete von Hendrik wissen, das heißt, die dürfen nicht 100 pro verschlüsselt sein, da müssen gewisse Metadaten noch lesbar sein, zum Beispiel, wie aktiv ist dieses Paket gerade, wie laut ist das Paket gerade und so weiter und so fort.
Und es gibt Infrastruktur, die kaputt gehen würde, wenn man einfach verschlüsselte Sachen drüber leiten würde und deswegen ist das in diesem S-Frame-Standard abgebildet.
Ich lege das einfach mal direkt daneben
in unsere Shownotes Plus, so der Vollständigkeit
halber.
Und
das
MLS und S-Frame.
Ich würde mich wundern, wenn Matrix für
seine Videokonferenzen vielleicht auch schon S-Frame
vorliegen. Das wäre eigentlich ganz cool.
Gibt es auch JavaScript-Diplementierung von?
Muss ja wahrscheinlich auch, ja.
Cool.
Sonst haben wir nur noch
einen Link jetzt tatsächlich mit unseren Shownotes.
Hast du das gelesen?
sonst können wir es auch für nächstes Mal
lassen. Es gibt eine schöne,
ich schmeiße es mal unausgesprochen
in die
Show Notes mit rein oder unvorgelesen
in die Show Notes mit rein und zwar ein
von Cory Doctorow
ein 9-Minute-Read
Teslas Dieselgate
How DRM let Tesla defraud
everyone of its customers
und das war der Artikel, der mir
vorhin, ich wusste, dass ich das neulich
mit DRM und Apple irgendwo schon mal gelesen hatte
erzählt hast, du glaubst an Apple und dass sie
Sicherheit nach vorne stellen.
Wird hier erwähnt,
DRM ist auch der Grund dafür, dass Apple zwar
sagen kann, dass ihnen deine Sicherheit und deine
Privatsphäre am Herz liegen, aber sie können
dich halt trotzdem überwachen, ohne dass du es nachvollziehen
kannst, weil du die Software nicht
lesen kannst. Das stimmt.
Guter Artikel und hier
drin irgendwo verlinkt war auch
Elon Musk.today und das ist
einfach nochmal witzig vorzulesen. Ist das ein
Link oder ist einfach bloß mein Browser kaputt
und ich kann es nicht anklicken? Was muss ich machen, um
kann ich direkt irgendwie aus
mal, äh, Dings,
ich gehe auf Scribe, nee, was mache ich?
Scribe.rip
RIP
und dann den gesamten anderen
Link hinten dran. Ja, funktioniert
Wahnsinn.
Elon Musk.today
Like Donald Trump,
but for Nerds.
Ach, es gibt auch Donald Trump
today wahrscheinlich. Ach, es war diese Seite.
Waiting on the Content Moderation Council.
So Sachen, die, die,
zu versprechen, die er mal gemacht hat.
Die er mal gemacht hat und wie lange es her ist
und dass die immer noch nicht eingetreten sind.
Tesla will find itself.
We should credit Tesla owners
$100 if we
change appointments
with less than 24 hours notice.
Hat er auch immer gesagt.
Offenbar kein Problem.
Die eingetreten.
Sachen wie
Full self driving.
Superfast Starlink hat dafür
891 Tagen behauptet. Jetzt müssen wir
diese Folge aufgenommen haben.
Und es ist immer noch nicht eng drin.
Space Ventilators.
Er hat mal gesagt, dass ein Tesla wie ein Boot
funktioniert und du eigentlich mit deinem Tesla
für eine kurze Zeit einfach ins Wasser fahren kannst,
weil sie gesielt sind
und sie keinen Intake haben, kein Exhaust.
Ja, das ist in etwa so wasserdicht
wie dein iPhone.
1279 Days since Elon Musk
consumers that Teslas can safely function as a boat
for short periods of time.
Was zum Teufel.
Klingt doch fantastisch.
Wenn du so überlegst, die ganzen
Projekte von
Elons Firmen sind halt alle
übelste Moonshots.
Also das, was Cory Doctorow
hier über Tesla schreibt, ist schon
ganz schön augenöffnend.
SpaceX
macht ziemlich coole Sachen, aber es gibt
ja noch andere Firmen, die momentan irgendwie gute
Raketenentwicklungsarbeit
leisten. Dieses Starlink-Projekt,
ist das wirklich
was, was sich trägt?
Also ich kenne ein paar Nutzer von Starlink
tatsächlich. Auch
hierzulande, die halt beschissenere
Leitungen haben zu ihrem Haus und deswegen Starlink
nutzen, weil es besser läuft.
The Boring Company und alles, was
die machen? Das ist, ja,
ich meine... Das ist einfach bloß bescheuert.
Das ist ja ein reiner
Spaßfaktor, oder? Dass du Klammenwerfer
rausbringst. Nein,
The Boring Company, die irgendwie dafür sorgen,
dass du die Werbung dafür machen,
aktiv, dass du in deiner Stadt bitte nicht
den ÖPNV ausbauen musst,
weil wir bald Tunnel unterirdisch bauen.
Diese Tunnel sind so eine
dumme Idee.
Ich meine, Flammenwerfer, klar würde ich
auch nehmen, auf jeden Fall. Es gibt ja diese
Referenzimplementierung, in Anführungsstrichen,
von diesem Tunnel, bei L.A.
irgendwo ist das, oder in L.A.,
wo du halt da hingehst und dann setzt du dich
in einen Tesla, der gefahren wird von professionellen Fahrern,
also können maximal drei Leute sein.
Las Vegas.
Genau. Und dann fährst du halt diese
100 Meter durch den Tunnel durch,
wo du viel mehr wartest, als wenn du zu Fuß
gelaufen wärst draußen. Und es sieht so
fucking scary aus, in diesem Tunnel zu sein.
Es ist super creepy. Es ist eine Todesfalle.
Es gibt ja nicht mal Platz, dann nebenher zu laufen, wenn was passiert.
Also, dass das überhaupt genehmigt
wurde, ist schon krass. Aber
Las Vegas ist ja so eine Mafia-Stadt.
Deswegen fahren da halt auch nur professionell angestellte
Fahrer, die der Tesla sagen, und nicht du selber.
Jetzt wird das halt in zwei Tagen schon zu
Zwischenfällen. Meinst du, die sind qualifiziert?
Naja, es sind Leute, die ausgebildet werden,
die wissen, auf was sie achten müssen.
Langsam fahren, vorsichtig fahren
und keine Ahnung,
was sich die Leute aussteigen lassen.
Das doesn't make me feel safe.
Und die haben halt Teslas da vor Ort
und essentiell haben die halt die dämlichste Form
von ÖPNV nachgebaut.
Also so, nimm eine U-Bahn
und ersetze jedes einzelne Feature
durch die dümmere Version davon.
Es gibt so ein schönes,
es gibt auch dieses
Nature keeps reinventing crabs.
Es gibt auch so
Tech Billionaires Keep Reinventing Buses.
Einfach,
im Endeffekt, wenn du es dann wirklich umsetzt
und alle Fehler behebst mit dem System,
dann hast du wieder einen Bus oder eine Straßenbahn.
Ist doch auch wunderschön,
dass das keine neuen Konzepte braucht,
die aktuell existieren, halt nur nicht in den USA
ein Funktional.
Auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt auch in den USA ÖPNV-Systeme
und manche Städte haben sogar recht gute,
aber es gibt auch Gründe, warum die im Großteil
nicht existieren, beziehungsweise diesen super beschissenen
Ruf habe, wo sie gar nicht mal schlecht sind.
Und das ist halt einfach
sad.
Deswegen spiele ich
City Skylines und schaffe meine Straßen
ab und meine Städte funktionieren halt
nicht mit nur ÖPNV.
Ich habe
in einem Video, es gibt ja tatsächlich
in letzter Zeit wirklich einen Boom,
so einen City Planning Boom
oder so einen
ÖPNV Boom,
Stadtplanungsboom,
ganz viele YouTube-Channels und
Influencer oder
Content-Producer, die über sowas reden.
Ich kann nur den herrlichen
YouTube-Channel NotJustCars,
äh, ne, Quatsch, haha, das war
ein Gag-Video, NotJustBikes,
äh, NotJustBikes
empfehlen, und da gab's
auch das, der hatte auch neulich in einem Interview,
warum es so ein, vielleicht ist das auch
bloß meine Bubble, warum es
gerade so ein Boom an
City-Planning-Content gibt.
Aber der hatte auch in irgendeinem Video neulich drin SimCity.
SimCity war eigentlich an amerikanische Städte angelehnt.
Das war Climate Town.
Aber dann hat man festgestellt,
wenn man die amerikanischen Städte wirklich so gestalten würde,
wie amerikanische Städte aussehen würden, was Parkplätze angeht,
würde es total hässlich von oben aussehen.
Stimmt, Parkplatzflächen gibt es nicht.
Da sind die Parkplatzflächen
in den SimCity-Städten
viel zu klein für die Zahl
der Autos.
Maximal Straßenparking oder so, aber du hast keine
Parkplätze mitgebaut, keine Parkhäuser,
kein Underground-Parking.
Macht man das bei City Skylights?
Wo gehen die Autos dahin?
Die sind auch einfach weg. Aber City Skylines 2
ist vielleicht anders, keine Ahnung.
Das sieht echt fantastisch aus. Es kommt im Oktober raus
und es sieht so gut aus.
Es läuft ja nur auf Windows nicht mehr auf Mac.
vielleicht macht man das mit GPT.
So, wir sind jetzt schon an einem
relativ hohen Zeitpunkt angekommen.
Wollen wir noch jeder einen Pick in den Raum werfen?
Ich habe meinen vorhin schon eingeworfen, mach du mal noch einen Pick.
Gut, also ich...
Schade, ich dachte, es ist eine Minute Zeit, um mal nachzugucken.
Und zwar, ich mache was ganz, ganz, ganz Kleines
für den einen
Rust-Entwickler da draußen.
Und zwar, wenn ich immer, wenn ich
Leuten Sachen zeige,
mache ich nächste Woche erst wieder mit meinem Team.
Was muss man über Rust alles wissen? Was sind so leichte
Einstiege? Finde ich es total schön, dass es
.rs-Domains gibt.
Das ist echt wahr. Das ist cool.
Bei Serbien, oder?
Das kann sein.
RS ist auch die Dateiendung von Rust-Dateien
und
es gibt so die Webseite von
Async Stood Runtime ist async.rs
und es gibt eine
alternative
Crates, einen alternativen Crates
Index, der heißt
lib.rs und die
Dokumentation von Crates
findest du unter docs.rs
und die Dokumentation
der Standardbibliothek findest du unter
std.rs, std.rs
Das ist doch alles Freies.
Es liegt ja auch praktisch, dass die Serben
eine andere Sprache sprechen und nicht Englisch.
solche typischen Begriffe
zu geben. Und was ich jetzt neulich
neulich war von einem Jahr, aber
ist mir neulich wieder bewusst geworden, gefunden habe
und was ich jetzt häufiger benutze, wenn es
Updates zu Crates gibt, ist
div.rs
und bei div.rs kannst du auch hinten dran
einfach den Namen von irgendeinem Crate eingeben,
dann könntest du zum Beispiel mal Tokyo eingeben
mit i
div.rs slash Tokyo
und dann siehst du einfach den
Source-Code von der aktuellen Version und kannst da
eine andere Version auswählen
und dann siehst du einfach ein Diff zwischen beiden
Versionen dieser veröffentlichten
Library und
das kann man sich relativ schnell
angucken, was ist da passiert.
Finde ich sehr schick.
Allein schon den Change-Aktur-Diffen ist ja schon cool.
Das alleine ist bereits was wert.
Weil Seiten...
Vielleicht kann ich noch mal einen zweiten Pick hier reinwerfen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie du das handhabst.
Bei GitHub gibt es Releases
und in Releases
stehen Daten drin über
was in dem Release alles drin ist.
Die werden nicht automatisch
aus Tags erzeugt. Es gibt auch
Tags. Tags zählen als
Lightweight Releases. Tags zählen als
Lightweight Releases und ich habe leider den Eindruck,
also die Leute machen es alle ein bisschen
anders oder benutzen es alles. Ich benutze zum Beispiel
Releases fast gar nicht. Ich schreibe lieber
Change Logs.
Mache ich auch nicht. Bei mir gibt es nur Tags.
Tags, das war es.
Und das ist aber immer fies, weil ich
wenn ich eine Library update oder
wenn ich auch eine Dependency update oder irgendwas,
wüsste ich schon gerne, was wirklich
in der letzten Version passiert ist. Warum zum Geier
hat der jetzt eine neue Major-Version rausgebracht
und das Erste,
was man machen kann, ist wirklich zwischen den Tags
auf GitHub und Diff anzeigen.
Schön wäre es, wenn es irgendwie Release-Nodes gibt
oder Change-Logs gibt.
Und wenn du das alles nicht hast,
kannst du wenigstens Diff-RS verwenden.
Aber
ich habe eine schöne
GitHub-Action für dieses S-Frame-Repo
benutzen wirst und ich würde es gerne noch
demnächst auf meine anderen Repos ziehen.
Release Please.
Einfach eine GitHub-Action,
die macht für dich Releases.
Es macht quasi Continuous
Release oder Continuous Deployment.
Nicht wirklich Deployment, weil es kein Service ist, aber
wenn du
Semantic Commit Messages beachtest,
dann hast du permanent einen Pull-Request
offen.
Also in der Konfiguration, die wir haben, du kannst auch machen,
dass sobald du was auf Master mercht,
wird ein Release gemacht. Du kannst es aber auch so
konfigurieren, dass du
normal auf Master mercht und nichts passiert,
außer, dass es immer einen Pull-Request mit dem
nächsten Release gibt. Und wenn du den
mercht, wird das
released nach dem Mergen, was ich ziemlich
gut finde. Also bei dem Repo, wir haben gerade heute
erst einen Release gemacht, aber wenn
du was auf Master mercht, dann sieht er halt den
Semantic Commit Messages
an.
Wäre das Major,
Minor oder Fixed Release.
Macht ein PR auf, so würde der
nächste Release aussehen. Die Version hätte er,
den Changelog hätte er.
Und wenn du den mercht,
dann baut er das durch und macht den Release of Crates.io für dich.
Finde ich cool.
Und das gibt es wahrscheinlich auch für andere Ökosysteme.
Ich habe mir in meinen Crates,
versuche ich irgendwie bislang eine Konvention zu halten,
habe ich so ein Bump-Version-Skript,
was mir einmal das aus den Commit-Messages ausrechnet,
den Commit erzeugt, das taggt,
das dann den Change-Log erzeugt,
den mergt und ist dann released,
damit der Change-Log mit in dem releaseten Package drin ist.
Aber das hier ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Pack ich mit in die Show Notes.
Das ist jetzt speziell
für Rust natürlich,
aber
sie referenzieren hier auch andere Projekte
für andere Sprachen.
Das hier basiert,
von was abgeleitet, was glaube ich aus der Haskell-Welt kommt.
Und jetzt,
da ihr von dem Konzept wisst, findet ihr das vielleicht auch
für eure Lieblingsprogramm-Sprache. Vielleicht gibt es ja sowas
für Swift oder für
JavaScript. Das ist ein gutes Konzept,
Auf jeden Fall. Vor allem für Leute wie mich, die
1000 in New Tags setzen und das war's.
Genau. Aber ich bin zum Beispiel,
seitdem ich von conventional
Commit Messages
weiß und das auf Arbeit
benutze, bin ich da auch sehr
strikt, was das angeht.
Ich habe lange gelitten,
das als CI-Check
in meine Repos einzubauen,
bis ich es endlich mit einer
Action hingekriegt habe, die das für mich validiert.
Aber wenn dir Leute
Pull-Requests aufmachen, du bist ja sehr dankbar, dass Leute
an dein Projekt mitarbeiten und irgendwas
fixen wollen oder es benutzen.
Wenn du dann immer der Arsch sein musst, der sagen muss,
kannst du bitte
deine Commit-Message noch ändern?
Und wenn du aber einen CI-Check hast,
der dann nicht grün wird,
dann kannst du sagen,
sorry, also ich, es ist halt noch,
bist du nicht das Arschloch, weißt du?
Aber es dokumentiert
auch besser. Ich meine, wenn du
einen Pull-Request aufmachst in einem fremden Repo
und dann wartest du eine Woche und dann sagt dir die Person,
ja, ist cool, aber schreib mal oben,
sonst würde ich es nicht. Ist das scheiße,
oder beschissener, als wenn du den Pull-Request
aufmachst und dir sagt halt direkt die CI,
ja, wir haben aber hier ein standardisiertes Format,
so schaut das aus. Und dann bin ich ja eh noch
dran und cool, dann kann ich das ja direkt umschreiben.
Das fühlt sich als Nutzer auch sehr viel besser an.
Was ich manchmal mache, ist, wenn es eine Weile rumliegt, das passiert
bei mir auch, dass ich irgendwie ein PR aufhabe und dann kann ich
eine Zeit lang einfach nicht reagieren, weil ich
nicht mehr so viel Zeit habe, nebenbei
auch noch so Sachen zu mitten.
dann sage ich irgendwann, ach das ist cool
die drei Änderungen, die ich noch
gebeten hätte, die kann ich auch fix selber machen
und dann kannst du als
Repo-Owner
auf den Pull-Requests
auch auf den Branch von den Leuten pushen
Das ist zwar irgendwie ein bisschen weird
weil du den da unter dem Arsch weg
auf deren Versionen
rumpuscht. Finde ich aber super, dass das
vor zwei Jahren, wenn das Feature reinkam
das ist toll, das ist so eine kluge Idee
Weil manchmal mache ich es einfach so
das mit der Comment Message, das ändere ich einfach fix.
Ja, es muss ja nicht mal das sein, vielleicht ist es ja auch einfach
noch irgendwas, was
wir haben hier ein komisches Setup und ja, das ist komplex,
ich kann es dir im Text hier erklären, aber
wenn die Person fein damit ist, dann kann ich es
auch einfach machen und zeigen und
ja, das müsste so hier aussahen. Oh cool,
da können wir ja direkt kooperieren. Dann arbeitest du
auf dem selben Brand oder kann die andere Person ja auch noch mal was
dazu pushen. Das ist ja
eigentlich echt cool, dass das geht und ich
mag, dass das ein Feature ist.
Mittlerweile glaube ich sogar ein Opt-out Feature,
kein Opt-in-Feature mehr.
Ja, bei manchen Leuten habe ich schon gemerkt,
war es wieder deaktiviert.
Ist ja okay, wenn du es nicht magst, fühlt sich ein bisschen komisch an.
Es ist, ja,
ich kann auch verstehen, dass Leute
das ausmachen, muss ich sagen. Also ich fände es auch weird,
muss ich sagen, dass dann plötzlich auf deinem
Repo, was der
Fork von dem Ding ist, jemand anders.
Ist halt auch die Frage, warum du den Fork hast.
Ist das dein Fork, oder hast du den Fork,
nur weil du diesen Patch hier machen musst?
Es ist ja unter deinem Namespace auf GitHub.
Es fühlt sich trotzdem so ein bisschen wie deins an.
Auch wenn es ein Fork ist, nur immer schnell auf einem anderen
Hat man eigentlich komplett Rechte in diesem Fork
oder nur auf diesem Branch von dem Fork?
Ich glaube, du kannst nur auf den,
wenn ein PR, ich glaube sogar,
du kannst nur auf den Branch pushen,
von dem der PR aufgemacht wurde.
Dann ist doch super, das ist doch wunderbar.
Das ist, genau.
Du kannst natürlich auch dahergehen,
nee, Quatsch.
Man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist hinreichend
für akronomisierbar Folge.
Hinreichend.
Das Quota einer akronomisierbaren Folge wurde erreicht.
Das wäre auch ein schöner Podcast-Titel.
Hinreichend, aber nicht korrekt.
Das gibt es auch irgendwie bei Logik,
korrekt, aber nicht hinreicht.
Das ist ein schöner Titel.
In den letzten zwei Sekunden stand der,
gefällt mir.
Ja, also
eigentlich hätte das, wenn wir mal
von vorne anfangen einen neuen Podcast machen,
nennen wir den so.
Das ist wie HTTP 203,
auch der beste Podcast-Titel.
Es ist
http203, wenn du mal auf
http.cat slash 203 gehst,
Non-Authoritative Information.
Das sind wir.
Jetzt das gelesen hat, dachte ich mir,
Mist, das hätte mein Podcast sein können.
Echt, das sind wir.
Nee, der Podcast ist...
Ach, den gibt's schon.
Den gibt's schon.
Der ist von, ich hab die Namen vergessen,
aber die beiden Leute, die das machen,
die sind eigentlich Authorities
auf ihrem Gebiet. Also eigentlich ist der
das ist nur Humble.
Anyway,
vielen Dank, dass ihr mich sicher dran gelebt seid.
Das ist ein Google-Podcast.
Das ist Surma und wie heißt der andere?
Ich vergesse mal, wie der heißt.
Aber der ist wirklich gut.
Es könnte dich jetzt auch mehr interessieren,
jetzt wo du Web-Entwickler bist.
Das war Akronomisierbar
Folge 55.
Vielen Dank fürs bis hier durchhalten.
Wenn ihr bis hier durchgehalten habt, dann könnt ihr
unseren neuen Podcast-Titel,
nee, den müssen wir jetzt in die Folge mit reinschreiben.
Schreibt uns gerne
unsere, die Korrekturen
zu all dem Mist, den wir hier behaupten, der gar nicht stimmt.
Freundlich
in Matrix in unserem Channel,
den wir verlinken, oder in unseren
neuen Kommentaren. Merkt euch, eure
GitHub-Usernames sind damit verknüpft.
Es müsste theoretisch
dann auch auf euren GitHub-Pages
auftauchen, in der
Activity-Leiste, dass ihr
participatet an dem
Akronomisierbar-Kommentar-Repo.
Das ist das
Repo der Seite direkt. Das ist in unserer
Org. Also dieses Repo
heißt auch Akronomisier.bar.
Und da macht das eine Discussion. Die erste Person
macht die Discussion quasi auf, wenn sie noch nicht existiert.
Aber in diesen
Activity-Graphs auf deiner
GitHub-Profil-Seite taucht auf, wenn du in irgendwelchen
Sachen kommentierst, glaube ich.
Auch wenn es eine Discussion ist? Ja, wäre cool.
Ist doch wunderbar.
Also, bleibt freundlich.
Oder schreibt uns auf den Matrix, geht auch.
Genau. In dem Sinne,
jetzt ist bestimmt
bereits der nächste Podcast in eurem Podcatcher
in der Playlist danach und bei dem wünschen wir euch
viel Spaß in 3, 2,
1.